Aaron Rodgers detective Aaron Rodgers
what a week baby not only is it Odell
Beckham jr. week not only is it Aaron
Rodgers gets a new contract week guess
what today is
man you know cremes your birthday
present is Aaron Rodgers gets a new deal
that could get them a eighty million
dollars by Mark yeah that's that's I
just feel like that's the kind of
leverage I have in the media these days
left go PR gato della contra and be
berated for around my birthday - he's
like you know what I'm gonna let Aaron
Rodgers have sure his birthday yes
Malita I'll be the appetizer
we gave Simms a bunch of crap for naming
our fantasy team team Oh del Rodgers you
know they kind of like doing it we got
Odell and Rogers nobodies but I know the
team is Odell Rogers I am they're easily
the two guys that we love the most in
the NFL and they both got monster Cup
it's it son so awesome it really is and
I also like the fact that they didn't
sit there to screw their football team I
didn't I know they did not I don't like
that looked at the details Odell Beckham
jr. is not making much more than Antonio
Brown or Sammy Watkins and you ear were
thinking if he holds out 420 it could be
tough right so what he did was something
friendly to the football team and took a
number that's a little less but the
Giants also said you know what we'll
front-load your contract and you're
gonna make over 60 something million
dollars your first three years in the
NFL yeah
and then he's gonna have three years
left which I expect him to still be the
best receiver in football at that time
and they're gonna go okay well rip it up
and start a new one have you seen enough
details and Rodgers to know he didn't
screw them over - uh yeah I mean Rodgers
is barely gonna outdo Matt Ryan and Kirk
Cousins they're such big numbers can I
have Joshua Lee DeWyze yes this is
courtesy van by the way by the way just
so everyone doesn't know Aaron Rodgers
got a new contract I told my guts
right alright so 134 million dollar
extension that could be worth up to a
hundred and eighty million in total
money I love when you can make forty
five million dollars more money the
extension includes nearly a hundred and
three million in total guarantees
another record amount and has an annual
average value of thirty three point five
million one hundred and five million
Kirk Cousins got 84 guaranteed he walked
away from ninety guaranteed from the
Jets and here comes Rogers with a
hundred and three
right again this is Matt Ryan had a
hundred right I believe guaranteed as
well so this is all Adam Schefter the
total the total max value of the deal is
between one hundred and seventy six and
one hundred and eighty million based on
a four million dollar incentive tied to
helping the Packers make the playoffs
and finishing top three in quarterback
rating in the league so according to the
deal Matt Ryan got a hundred guarantees
according to the deal Rogers gets sixty
seven million by the end of the 2018
calendar year and then an additional 13
million before March 17th of 2019
getting him to 80 million dollars by st.
Patty's Day follow the rainbow oh my
gosh he's be walking through the streets
of Appleton just being like beers on me
does he deserve it Chris oh come on I
mean he really he could have argued and
made you know an argument for more
really I mean really at the end of the
day I mean for a yearly salary what he's
making again you know I think it just
shows that the guy yeah he's gonna be
the tie highest-paid quarterback in
football she should be four he's 34
he's definitely got like three to four
years of primary and Rodgers left right
yeah and I think he will last longer
than that because his arm is it's never
gonna die out he's always gonna have a
great arm it's never gonna be like oh
well Rodgers can't throw the 20 yard
comeback anymore that he'll be able to
do that at 60 yeah so yeah I'm just glad
it got done we don't have to hear about
it now he's happy and he can be the
leader of the team and they can go
forward what please don't say that again
he can go forward no just don't I
already have that news I don't need
Simms finding out we're gonna do that in
a second
okay uh he doesn't want me to know where
teddy bridgewater sign I traded to yet I
don't know yet either I'm so excited
that you don't know right oh I just saw
it oh you're killing us I didn't mean to
I'm just on NFL stuff and it popped up
out of nowhere it's not I can I sue the
internet for doing pop-ups on my
computer I didn't ask for it yes please
yes I'm not done talk about Rogers all
right can you so there's gonna be a lot
of people I already had a friend that in
a group chat responded with all he does
is throw a football and there's gonna be
some people that say he only has one
Super Bowl all of the people that love
Sims and Lefko know that we believe that
Aaron Rodgers is the greatest
quarterback you've ever seen right can
you summarize your feelings about Aaron
Rodgers and why he definitely deserves a
contract of this magnitude yeah I mean
as we heard from Tony Romo yesterday
he's the most physically gifted
quarterback we've ever seen that's
without question what did he tell us he
said when if one of those things we were
talking about off camera he's like when
Rogers gets to 25-yard completions cuz
Rogers made an amazing play when most
quarterbacks got a 25-yard completions
because their offensive game planner
dialed up a great play and it was very
easy to come by Aaron Rodgers is the
greatest one-man band and the history of
the sport I mean yeah he only won one
Super Bowl and he only had to play the
four greatest games in the history of
the sport to win it I mean people go
back and look to the 2011 playoffs I
mean he went on a tear there that we've
never seen before in the sport I mean he
literally took it over
including the Super Bowl where he made
throws against the Pittsburgh Steelers
were the better football team that day
but Aaron Rodgers the best offense in
the NFL right but Aaron Rodgers the best
player in football and he overcame it
with lasers down the middle of the field
where it looked like Ryan Clark was
gonna intercept or Troy Polamalu was
intercepted and instead it ended up
being 25-yard touchdown passes or
30-yard gains so again you know the
rings thing I always get annoyed that I
think is such a stupid thing to say it's
a team sport Aaron Rodgers certainly
hasn't had the number of Hall of Famers
throughout his career that may be an a
Tom Brady has had and he definitely
hasn't had the play callers that a Brady
or a breeze or
Jared Goff or Jimmy Garoppolo has I mean
I'm like I've always said and you and I
am and we know this is I mean a lot of
people in the end of a laugh at Green
Bay's offense they laugh at it they just
go oh my gosh it's it's pitiful
it's one of the worst in the league and
yet he still is dominates people with it
every year it's 38 and 7 or 39 and 8 you
know is - touchdown interception race
yes he's the greatest gunslinger we've
ever seen in the sport at the same time
as being the greatest protector of the
ball we've ever seen in the sport and
it's not even close so I don't know what
else more to say about it who's the last
running back to Aaron Rodgers has had I
know it's it's you know the kid Ryan
Grant may be right I mean it's it's
something like that it's nothing special
you know Aaron rocks Aaron Rodgers is
towards the top of his team's I don't
know what rushing yards total yes I mean
I don't know but someone who's talking
in my ear
the the he can lead his team in rushing
some years but the way he scrambles
around and do everything when the Green
Bay Packers come to town its Aaron
Rodgers and the Green Bay Packers are
coming to town that's really one of the
only people in football that has that so
you know people like yeah maybe Brady
but I think Belichick is first braid
billing usually when he comes in New
York it's like man Bill Belichick and
the patients are coming to that Tom
Brady - dammit he doesn't get first
billing Rodgers gets first billing and
Rodgers just being around people in
general I mean just how many defensive
players have we had on our podcast you
know I was going to say that we always
have people and they always say Rodgers
is great have you ever met anybody that
hasn't said Rodgers is one of the most
talented quarterbacks they've ever seen
have you ever met them not oh not least
like people I respect that's what I mean
the respect people ya know like whether
it's boomer esiason Troy Aikman my old
coach Jon Gruden I was texting him two
years ago remember even actor right and
once played that amazing first half yes
and Rogers had that incredible touchdown
down the sideline right texted group
it's actually Gruden during the game I
said man I think Rogers is the greatest
player I've ever seen and he text back
man I think you're right I mean he's
he's unbelievable yes
it's it's it's a skill set that is so
special
I don't think TV always does it justice
the quickness of his rating so either
the strength of his arm the ball
whistles through the air and he could do
it effortlessly and then he's one of the
greatest athletes ever to play in the
position and we can go back to Jason
Garrett after the divisional playoff
game a few years ago remember what he
said he's gonna go down as one of the
three greatest players to ever lace them
up as what he said and Jason Garrett's
been in football for like thirty years
behind Troy Aikman and his dad was in
football for 34 years yes we are gonna
get to all of our divisional winners or
Super Bowl picks it's we're going to
everything I have sheets upon sheets and
when I tell you that me and Sims have
not shared our information we were doing
a little teaser like practice runs for
our new show and like he was like oh so
that's where you have them like we are
trying to guess each other's teams too
uh hello teddy bridgewater Saints yeah
teddy bridgewater to the Saints and
Brett Hundley to the Seahawks yes you
said on Monday
Seahawks need to back up yeah I think
Brett Hundley was looking real good in
this preseason yes he was he I was very
impressed by both him and DeSean Kaiser
for the Packers yeah I think that's a
natural fit for him up there in Seattle
Teddy to New Orleans is very interesting
yeah we do not know what they got back
yet for him I can't imagine it's better
than a third
we'll find out probably as this shows
going on but Teddy Bridgewater backing
up Drew Brees
I feel like they've been looking for the
Brees replacement for the next few years
not a bad bet on this guy
no not a bad bet at all could be the guy
the future after Drew Brees he could
fill a lot of voids here right and yeah
I mean you're the New Orleans Saints
you're going for a super big fall in the
category of a Super Bowl team right they
are a lot like the Eagles where if Brees
went down
I can't go to Taysom Hill or Tom Savage
or Tom Savage Teddy can keep the ball
rolled right and these teddy fits in
that offense more than at a Stone Hill
or a Tom Savage by the way yeah I love
Taysom Hill yeah
like what an ascot potentially crap he
was an ultimate whoa big offseason this
yes he was but teddy bridgewater you see
the Saints getting him as an insurance
policy on a Super Bowl run exactly right
he is an insurance policy for a team
that I think has the legit chance to win
the Super Bowl
I think obviously they're telling you
they think that as well and I think it's
a double double edged sword and the fact
that yeah okay we're getting insurance
for this year and maybe next year but
maybe this guy could be our answer
through maybe his knee gets so much
better and everything starts to go in
the right direction that he he can
become the starter this is work this is
the best part about our show right now
as things are happening just details
home Teddy Bridgewater right crazy seen
tweets Tom palace arrow Jets players
were on the bus the bus stops they were
told Teddy Bridgewater had been traded
he waved goodbye got off the bus and
then they drove away
that's the Ennis oh there that's the end
have you ever seen anything like that
happen I I really the bus stopped Teddy
you've been traded bye guys see ya going
that's unbelievable so they were getting
ready to hunt even know who they're
playing in preseason game for because it
doesn't matter don't even watch film
this weekend if you watch film this
weekend I'm gonna be upset no I probably
won't other than a few young
quarterbacks weddings like that you
listen to me but give yourself a break I
know they'll go crazy when T two weeks
in a row I know damn Notre Dame's on me
too so but what the hell were you just
talking to you there's water on the I've
never been a part of anything like that
now I've been on planes where we're
waiting for Vince Young to get there and
things like that and whatever he doesn't
show up and Jeff Fisher says close the
door we're out of here whatever it is
but I can't say that I remember I really
was never a part of any real trades that
went down in a league I was in knew I
was very rare I know I was in New
England the year we traded for Aqib
Talib right and that was pretty cool and
special but this is life in the NFL it's
rare that it happens when you're on the
bus and you say goodbye but this time of
the year people disappear from the law I
didn't realize that the week before the
fourth week of the preseason would have
so
much contract news and team adjustments
but I would assume after the third
preseason game that's when everyone goes
let's finalize our fifty three exactly
now they have all that information they
can look at their salaries
I mean look Geno Atkins getting that
deal what and what was the plan yes
we're we're gonna get to predicting all
the teams Atkins four-year extension
through 2022 new contract worth sixty
five point three million twenty five
point five in the first year and then
more that more than half of the deal
he'll get thirty seven point five over
the first two year and then his sixteen
point three yearly average is the
highest annual rate signed by a 30-plus
year old non quarterback in NFL history
that I was gonna say man I felt calm I
know
Geno just destroyed the bills by himself
right but I thought that Geno had kind
of tailed off the last few years last
year he was definitely better two years
ago was definitely under well maybe he
was hurt I know yeah yeah and he was
never he had torn his ACL maybe three
years ago and you're after he was a
little underwhelming certainly wasn't
the guy well we got to remind everybody
what Geno Atkins was and what we do Geno
Atkins is Aaron Donald before Aaron down
now which is amazing because someone
posted a high school clip right of Aaron
Donald being asked who he models himself
afterwards and he didn't even let the
guy finish he left he goes oh that's
easy do you know Atkins right it's a
very similar type of body like that's so
funny that you said the compact muscle
guy right not like this hulking call his
Campbell six nine three thirty guy no
Gino Atkins is more of like six
one-and-a-half I'm guessing right around
that and you know really dense
three hundred to ninety eight 305
depending on his week of food eating
right but he is a CL in 2013 2013 yeah
so it took a good to two years I really
feel like last year was the first year I
saw him go like okay he's back to
[ __ ] the play up Geno Atkins and
lifting people and yes and just shooting
through gaps he's got unbelievable
explosive a super happy for Gina right
numbers make sense to you they do I mean
there's probably a hair hi
than I would have expected yeah but
again everybody's gonna remember the
salary caps up close to 170 million
these numbers are gonna go up yeah and
if you look at the people that are
around him at his position he's not
gonna be paid like Fletcher Cox no he's
not that guy so he shouldn't be he's not
gonna be Erin Donald when it's done
right literally like eight years old
right but now the Kiwanis orts the
Marcel Darius is the world I got it
Gerald McCoy damn Gina Watkins is every
bit as good as them right now so he's
another another front-loaded deal where
he gets more than half in the first two
years it's really that's where I am
happy to see and I hope this is where it
continues to go where organizations with
the players they like make them
front-loaded and make us if your pious
omits gonna be great well Tara will give
you a new contract they want you to play
great they want it to be good then you
win a superb right right I also feel
like Cincinnati's more willing to
overpay their guys because they don't
typically get free agents it's it's not
another place to go you're right so they
kind of keep them yes Tyler Lockett got
a pretty big deal - yeah the numbers
from now what is that that's three years
thirty 1.8 million he can earn up to
37.8 over the course of the deal and
he's got 20 million guaranteed that was
just surprising for a guy that I don't
even know if he's a number two yeah he's
kind of a number three but he also just
punts and kicks and he's super elusive
yes when you see that this is a fantasy
question do you think the team is
planning more things around him this
season I do I did mean I don't know I
can't remember who the hell I've talked
to I got in this conversation with the
Seahawks a little bit the other day I do
think that you're gonna see a whole lot
more of Tyler Lockett this year one Doug
Baldwin is not gonna be a hundred
percent all those for our fantasy drew I
know but I do
I think Lockett first of all he's a guy
that he can do a lot of different things
on the field he's very much similar to a
Brandon cooks in a lot of ways it's not
that far off of a player in my mind he
just hasn't been in an offense that's
knows knows how to utilize him because
he's been stuck in that crappy Seattle
system but that was shot and I'm here
they're they're going to do more and I
do think that locket will be the focal
point of the passing game I do yeah
because I don't I think Doug Baldwin
with his knee is not going to be able to
do some of the intermediate changing
direction type of route
all the other receivers they have or
kind of bigger receiver exactly right so
I think he can be not only the slot guy
that's gets some of the quick ones and
run after the catch but we've also seen
he as the speed to run a post over the
top and burn people I want to say
quickly it's crazy the money I thought
that was a lot of money it is but I
think for that guy you know and I
they're getting him for the low that you
got to think about they're getting them
they're going damn he might have a big
year and we don't want to have to pay
him 14 million a year like we did last
year or like some of these other guys so
let's do it now like I always think of
marques Goodwin Kyle this year with
marquise Goodwin they got him early on
in the off season to sign a deal because
Kyle knows damn I'm pretty good at
getting these fast guys open down the
field
let me not let him go with 9 touchdowns
and a thousand yards even then he's
asking for 15 million next year right
let's do it now and get you know chop
some of that that money away uh just
came in what the Jets got for Teddy
Bridgewater okay what do you think I'm
gonna search gonna be good and what's
gonna be bad what's gonna be good one's
gonna be yeah yeah I think it's I would
think it would be a legit mid round pick
like a third two for three I'm gonna say
it's a fourth round pick
third it's a third they went to three
huh yeah Wow
so that caught you they signed him for 1
million dollars
right he worked all offseason with Sam
darn 'old and they shipped him off for a
third-round play and it's more smart
move by the Jets very smart it really
was I mean I'm I'm impressed by the play
all together and it's smart by the
Jeff's
Jets it ends that conversation it's rams
Arnold for damned Arnold right and I
think it shows you that the Saints were
very concerned about their backup
situated they're willing to give up 1/3
for a backup quarterback that's that's
well I've already traded a first away if
to get Marcus Davenport this year it
means they're going on going all in and
it also means that they're looking at
their draft capital and they're going we
need guys let's get these guys right
quickly our fantasy team these will be
the guys that we'll be rooting for all
year pretty vocally on the show and
luckily it's a lot of guys that we root
for already yeah so the best part of
this honestly is I posted the picture
last night with
with our whole roster and we have gotten
people responding to us with everything
from A plus plus draft I don't know who
you're drafting with you got all these
guys - you guys are idiots - Jesus
Christ draft the whole team what do you
realize that aren't the SL FL is a 14
team League and I was explaining to you
like I've only done 12 team leagues man
it's hard to get good so here's what we
got so wide receiving core sick I think
so I'm going rounds 160 no no build the
roster what do you mean
okay fine round the sixteenth yeah no
I'm saying one - six - yeah yeah so
first pick Odell Beckham second which
was hilarious I didn't I wanted to take
DeAndre Hopkins but I thought for the
show for the pod yeah we gotta get Odell
yes second-round picks Devonta Freeman
third-round pick love Devonta Freeman he
thought you were mad Sims third round
Adam Phelan who you said deserve the
bigger contract not Stefon Diggs juju
Smiths Schuester
you can't go wrong with you Jamie the
best part is when he's dancin we get
your daily enjoy that's gonna be amazing
Plus like Devonta Freeman like oh man
I'm sick they're gonna feature him a lot
and that often fifth round Chris
Thompson
yes was Simza [ __ ] so I sent you like a
list of running backs and you were like
Chris Thompson he looks amazing you had
a little inside scoop well I had heard
from down in DC that he has looked very
good in practice and I feel like that
and I just think people forget that he
was the most explosive player on their
office a third down running back right
no he was running up the gut for 50 yard
touchdowns against the Los Angeles Rams
I mean he ran up the middle gets the
Eagles - I said I mean so he got hurt
against the Saints and also you know
what kind of quarterback would throw
their running back a lot yeah and our
team sounds great six-round Rex Burkhead
this was a left go pick that's all right
it's a good one though I think that Rex
of all the fantasy guys that I follow
all of them whisper Rexburg he's like
the guy
I also took him last year and he popped
at the end I feel good about seventh
round Rashad Penny this was a Sims pick
Sims went he's a first round pick
they're gonna want to make it work we
said what about Chris Carr someone in
the chat said did you mean to just draft
Chris Carson yeah and Sims was like no
they love me what are you hearing about
her shop any did they mean to draft
Rashad Penney at the end of the first
round oh that means they weren't that
happy
Chris Carson oh he just what he do break
a finger trust me
Rashad Penny's gonna be good Nelson
Aguilar
this was my pick good pick I say you
know we had him until today I said I
said he's a number one wide receiver on
the Eagles right now
I don't know when how Sean's coming back
I don't know who any of them are but I
do know that the quarterback is gonna be
Carson Wentz yeah and Nelson played well
T in the last yes he did ninth round
Jimmy G q yeah do it do it now Jimmy G Q
and a man meant to the moment - is Kyle
shad heads our favorite coach to the NFL
you proud of yourself and came up with
that was Brad I was also proud that our
viewers thought I was on the back porch
they know me very well they do yeah all
right we were excited because all the
other quarterbacks that were there was
like Stafford and all these innuendo
Jimmy G's could have yards touched and
you said yards or touchdowns or all we
want I just said then he's our guy he's
the most the safest one as long as this
is great so we get to root for Kyle and
Jimmy G Q we get to root for Odell yes
then we get to see juju dance I'm just
and I brought up to you last night that
we have Adam feeling after we talked a
couple weeks ago when Diggs got his
extension that they gave the all the
money to the wrong guy I know time outs
did I just say that you know he wasn't
less feeling yeah I know I told that
exact same thing I really missed it I'm
too busy studying our beautiful team
10th round Payton barber I start er in
the 10th row they're all lines gonna be
better and they do have weapons to worry
about in the pass game that's a good one
11th latavius Murray this was a okay
because I know our wide receivers are
good
maybe Dalvin is not healthy let me take
a shot in the 11th because latavius has
looked great in the precincts yeah and
he's just a guy that if someone's on a
bye we'll throw him in there but that
was a shot and also I didn't know what
to do there was like no one else to take
that was the pic where you turned to me
and said I have no idea what I'm doing
right yeah I
I don't think there's anything wrong
with it yeah there was a shot of the
dark twelfth round Ricci seals Jones so
that's our starting Titus well-timed
cough I just go okay bad offensive line
need to get the ball out quick this is
athletic tight end I also think we could
just pick up tight ends throughout the
season yeah you think we can I don't
know okay yeah there's nobody available
the Joe Smith is still available Joan
who's not still available dude he was
ranked 370 I'm just telling you he's
listed as a starter he starts down there
in Tennessee listen I'm telling you
that's what they're here to listen
listen Joe Neal Smith is going to be a
part of the Titans offense I'd see
because I read today that Matt Lafleur
ran a whole lot of 11 personnel and
really wasn't interested in getting the
12 of the 13 13th round Phillip Dorsett
14th round percent as a starter for the
Patriots right now I couldn't believe
that when you were texting me these are
the guys left I was like wait nobody
took who's gonna be Tom Brady's number
two target behind Rob Gronkowski that's
what's funny is everyone's going the
Patriots wide receivers right now or a
week and I go I just think they're
looking at cordarrelle Patterson and
Phillip Dorsett and going they're not
real I think the Patriots think they're
real I do too they're using Cordell
Patterson as a real receiver it's not
like oh we're just gonna let you run go
routes on the left side and return punts
no he is running all sorts of routes
Phillip Dorsett I think they're very
pleased with him and he can do
everything he can go deep he can be the
Julian Edelman type if that pack of that
works 14th round Giants d do you want
him I did Giants and we wanted Steelers
for then so until someone took them and
then what was the other one I texted you
as Giants and browns the Browns play to
my picks what scares me for the brown
yeah I they're scary things with the
Browns play a lot of good often yes they
do
15th round Jaron brown that was a Sims
pick and 16th
Harrison bucer yeah what did a
Buttkicker for our team I mean Jaron
brown has been very good in the
preseason Doug Baldwin well he might
miss weeks this year you know that's
when people are like oh he'll be back
for week one just said he's never gonna
be 100% the whole year so he tweaks that
knee week you know that knee week to all
the sudden he has to mix miss we
three and four damn I was gonna graph
Doug Baldwin of my other draft and now
I'm like I don't want to deal with that
all year yeah I know it's a pain okay so
now we just did what nobody likes to do
which is listening to someone else's
fantasy team but I guess if you're
taking your fantasy drafts and you heard
Sims analysis yeah you could use what to
use I can't believe I did selfies that's
what I can't believe you know that
you're what you saw when you called Sims
time yeah I mean I called Sims the first
time to record him on FaceTime on
FaceTime and he answered the phone from
the toilet and I had to say call me back
put a shirt on and we'll do this again
in five minutes yeah I don't need to
root a pure analysis I was actually like
totally I was just like I don't need
your analysis a Monell Beckham while
you're in the bathroom
oh yeah shout out to Dan and John's the
wings place that josh thinks is the best
and I'll be honest they might be the
best work and he walks back in and he
goes you think we can post this and it's
a video of you on the toilet naked and I
was like are you kidding me I was like
just don't answer it I was like well I
wanted to make sure you wrote new I
wasn't like ditching you so I was really
young I was really worried about that I
was gonna be like call you back I don't
I just got caught in the I had gotten
home from work and it was hot as crap in
New York City so I like felt like I said
where's my clothes right I was into
getting some comfortable clothes I get
it yeah we've all been there all right
Wow it is time that was a whirlwind
opening half-hour of this I loved it 50
7.5 million dollar signing bonus like
that's where it's crazy gonna buy so
many leather jackets is so this is how
much does he give to Danica but I to
that rings gonna be serious dude this is
where this is wrong with the sport
though right right now he's not 42 times
better than that staffer he's not 3
times better than Odell Beckham jr. I
mean Odell's gonna make 60 million and 3
what's really funny is every time you do
this I agree with you but with Aaron
Rodgers I'm like
he might be three times better than
Odell if I had 3 Odell's an eel I'd
rather have a what's-his-name Aaron
Rodgers it is time Josh is going to
guide us we're gonna go through all the
divisions
we're gonna pick other division winners
give some stuff on every single team
this is our big season we're putting her
name on it damn the NSA was so stressful
fan bases do not get upset this is not
routing we are not trying to we're not
picking teams and rooting against your
teams we are going to be wrong there has
never been a prediction in the history
of man that has come out right right if
Sports Illustrated says you're winning
the Super Bowl
throw it out it doesn't matter Simza
left go though maybe it's gonna be
accurate right we've got accurate did
you feel when you got done well my time
the NFC I don't feel accurate I'm very
scared of the end of C the NFC I
couldn't even fill it out I kept like
going and racing things and then going
back let me check this schedule for the
record we've had some good years of
these playoffs right two years ago I got
10 out of 12 you did last year
I was wrong I trusted Reddit you
actually went five and seven five and
seven right now just nothing to brag
about but I also think that we're good
at spotlighting some teams to look at
last year Viking Saints right people
forget last year everybody was picking
careers in the Falcons right yes alright
so here's how this is gonna work so
we're gonna go lead we're gonna go
division by division I'm gonna say the
division I'm gonna ask each of you how
many playoff teams you have coming from
that division okay tell me tell me the
number okay from there
I like this we'll go with each of your
winners and then we'll talk about the
rest of the division after that so first
we're gonna do the divisions after that
we'll do playoff seedings we'll get a
look at what your brackets look like
yeah then we're gonna do the awards
predictions because just like in the
season like in the NFL you do the awards
a night before the Super Bowl right and
then we'll do the Super Bowl to close
out this you do the playoffs and the
Super Bowl after that yeah after you
pick each round yeah I got it hey we
doing the AFC yes so we're gonna start
the AFC East
how many playoff teams for miss division
one for me all Patriots I have you don't
remember you're gonna know I have it
the document of this I have one but I
really almost put into okay so you have
one I have one okay I had two and then I
took a shower after I got done and I
went into changed you tell you what you
almost at the Dolphins then I did yeah
see the Patriots we need really your
that though all the Dolphins are one of
those teams sorry Josh no no the doctors
are one of those teams that were like I
think people are under estimating so
start with the Patriots yeah you're
gonna give your look at the team should
he do the team look first and I do some
of the schedule yeah I think that works
okay so you go first yes I mean the New
England Patriots come on where do we
want to start yeah okay
they lost a few players how many wins
you got him I'm gonna say there are like
you know I didn't pick exact wins but
you weren't supposed to do that robbery
yeah I know you don't know I'm gonna
Matt well I think it's gonna be illegal
11 in five-year yes welcome we're along
there but either way you know augment
align change is not concern doesn't
bother me at all Tom Brady's still gonna
be phenomenal I don't care that Julian
Edelman is not there there's still
enough receivers and running backs to go
around right that they will find ways to
get it done okay so I look at that they
were pretty good in the Super Bowl last
year without you know Julian Edelman yep
and the year before without Rob
Gronkowski so we know they can make it
work
defense I do have questions a little bit
like I think they're front sevens gonna
be a whole lot better than it was last
year the secondary thing is going to be
certainly the thing I have my eye on I
look at it and I'm an and they don't
have that other guy to me they get their
toughest games at home right Green Bay
Minnesota Houston Kansas City all have
to come to Foxborough yeah the two games
that are gonna be interesting from my
mind week two at Jacksonville week 15 at
Pitt that one could be super interesting
who did you have kind of coming in
second you guys both nearly put the
dolphins in the playoff I I mean they
were a team that I talked around playing
wild cards I've thought about this for a
long time I don't think people realize
that the Dolphins were expected to maybe
be a playoff team last year right people
forget week 1 was canceled because the
hurricane they lost a home game they
didn't have a bye and
had to go to London and Tannehill tours
ACL and they signed Cutler like two
weeks before the year half exactly and
week two which was their opening game on
the road against the Chargers they're
starting middle linebacker went AWOL
before the game do you remember that yes
Lawrence Timmons yes so they don't
you're right so I want to quit this is a
team that we I think a lot of people are
looking at the Dolphins going oh they
were bad last year they're gonna be bad
again last year was a special
circumstance I don't think people are
realizing that I also think Tannehill
was having the best year of his career
with GaSe before his injury was I think
the toughest stretch of their schedule
is weeks 14 to 16 which is why I took
them out of the playoff race it's home
against New England at Minnesota home
against Jacksonville really really tough
but I like them because Buffalo that
first six of the this first six of seven
are very winnable other than New England
it's Tennessee the Jets the Raiders the
Bengals the bears Lions I they could
start off really strong it could I agree
I mean I'm everything you said I agree
with Kenyan Drake is special into the
backfield
they have receivers to go around this is
Adam GaSe I hear everyone go the novel
and jury and I like yeah but now they
got like South Wilson and right and
darker and Amendola there's plenty of to
go around still there and the other
thing too is corner situations not bad
they're in - secondaries pretty dim
coming together you know you got Rashad
Minka yeah the kid from Xavier Howard
happen not though last year and then
they got pass rushers let's not forget
they traded for Robert Quinn oh yeah
with Cam Lake and now they saw also
Charles Harris it was their first-round
pick last year so first with you first
time I did this three weeks ago I was
looking at the Jets and I wanted to put
the Jets in they have the easiest
schedule in the NFL based off of success
last year from weeks one through six at
Detroit home against Miami at Cleveland
at Jacksonville Denver Indy it's great
pass defenses Ford Arnold to face when
you look at them as a whole not a lot of
other than Jacksonville obviously right
I like a lot of those teams their last
six games though the season I think are
very tough you gotta go up to Buffalo
Houston and Green Bay at New England but
I have them at around 7 & 9
yeah I think that Jets had a pretty good
year for
what they're expected to do I think
that's fair as well I I would say that
the Jets are one of those teams they're
gonna be a pain in the butt they're
gonna upset some teams that we would
have never thought they could be they're
not gonna lose many battles up front as
we've talked about they're big on both
sides of the ball so no ones are just
gonna come around and push the Jets
around the field that's the one thing I
can promise you it will be a rookie
starting quarterback you know run game
consistency things like that they're
gonna be in every game but yeah I agree
I think it's a seven and nine type of
year to him let's hit the bills before
we move on another rookie quarterback in
this division yeah so they have
legitimately the toughest schedule in
the NFL that is legitimately yes weeks
one through six right I'm just gonna say
this out loud
Josh Allen is going to go first game to
Baltimore yeah second game fell second
game the chargers yes third game in
Minnesota right so road game fourth game
in Green Bay fifth game home against the
Titans six game at Jadeveon Clowney and
JJ Watt with the Houston Texans awful
last year they were Owen six when the
turnover battle was tied or they were
worse in it they were eight and two when
they wanted turnovers you cannot bet on
every year that whole team was very
reliant on it think about the Falcons
game and all that stuff I had the bills
as a two and fourteen football oh crap
um I don't know if I'd go that hard of
them I mean I hear you when you look at
the schedule let's carry on
well no it's alright their team is their
team is definitely the least talented
and I also say you know hey listen they
got where they were last year is
McDermott's first year in Buffalo
Tyrod Taylor did protect the football I
had a favorable schedule that kind of
just worked out the right way for them I
think it was a year of everybody kind of
studying what McDermott does on defense
and everything like that and the fact
that they've lost some offensive linemen
and there's no receiver to be scared of
on the roster yeah that doesn't bode
well so I'm not gonna say three and
thirteen but I probably say like six and
ten okay all right two and 14 we're
moving on AFC North so I wanna I want to
do this one yes I would right because it
could be could be interesting so let go
how many playoff teams from this
division I have - okay - as well Oh
laughs go
give me your division winner first
Baltimore the Steelers let's talk it out
okay
I have Baltimore at like 12 and four
okay I've Pittsburgh at 11 and 5 I think
that Baltimore has an amazing start to
their schedule they do that I think is
gonna start them off great so obviously
we just talked about they play Buffalo
then they go to Cincinnati Denver and
then it's at Pittsburgh yeah but I like
that the Ravens are playing them that
early in the year don't forget they're
not gonna have Jimmy Smith for that game
exactly and Cincinnati's got their damn
numb I know I know what I do like is
Baltimore was five and two after their
bye last year they've been clicking for
a while now and I like what they look
like and then their last six weeks of
the year or against six of the not great
run defenses from last year that's why
people are so high on Alex Collins I'll
just get the Steelers to the Steelers
schedule if you look at the early year
two of their tougher games that are non
divisional the Falcons and Chiefs they
get them both at home I think if they
had to go to Atlanta and Kansas City
that's a little bit tougher but I like
they're starting schedule to their big
game will be New England in week 15 at
home yeah but yeah I think they're both
gonna be really good team I do too I
mean I think these are two of the cream
of the crops of the AFC in general two
of the few teams in the AFC that I could
see that could beat New England the
schedule is favorable for the Steelers
too I look at it like men Patrick
mahomes gonna have to make his first
road start right on the road in
Pittsburgh I don't think that bodes well
for him then they get a Jameis Winston
list yeah Tampa Bay and week three I
think both be three no heading into that
way yes exactly right so I expect
Pittsburgh to be three you know now
maybe they end up three and two after we
you know they got to play the Ravens the
Falcons but like you said the Ravens I
mean the Falcons are at home so that's
gonna be great yeah I just
pittsburgh's this is a different year
the procedures so high on the Steelers I
am the Steelers deed the team's speed
you know other than missing Ryan shazier
the secondary the front and I think Big
Ben is poised for one of the best years
we've seen him have in a few years with
juju along with it yeah I think this
deal which are poised for a big time
here but I do think the Ravens are right
there with them I mean I thought about
man do I want to make the Ravens win
this of
I don't think they're quite as quality
of a football team Sam come on the
Ravens that old line it's one of the
best in the sport they were ravaged by
injuries last year we've talked about
that a lot and I do think their
secondary is you know I know it's know
Jimmy Smith he'll be back in and that
would be good but the secondary is
definitely better than years past you
know Humphrey gets another year and he
got the two safeties who are quality
good I was going to say I have the
Bengals coming in third yeah around
seven and nine and I told us to watch
out for the Bengals yeah I know and then
I went back and I looked so here's what
scares me about the Bengals they don't
face Cleveland until weeks 12 and 15
I think Cleveland's gonna be a lot
better weeks 12 and 15 I would want to
face Cleveland early three of their
first four games are away yeah and it's
just not a great way to start and it's
one of them's at Carolina when them's at
Atlanta and you got a face Baltimore at
home the other thing is is I was just
looking at some of their stats last year
and I want to give a shout out really
quick to Warren sharp a lot of my stats
are gonna be from his book okay
he's he does a lot of work he's a great
guy bill lasers offense is so insanely
predictable from 13 personnel last year
they ran 92 percent of the time I don't
think he's going to change
I don't think bill lasers really had a
good year anywhere after he left Chip
Kelly Miami Cincinnati and I think that
he's not gonna move AJ green around for
another year I just think it's gonna be
the same old story for the Bengals right
and then I looked at the quarterbacks
the Bengals beat last year these are the
quarterbacks they beat Kaiser twice
Jacoby perset they only beat him by one
yea Osweiler they only beat him by three
Flacco they beat him by a miracle at the
end yes I think that Cincinnati I kind
of went oh they could be better but I
think they could end up being a lot
worse yeah they are if like a flip of
the coin type team they start out they
do they got talent on the team that
scares you will make you think but the
old line scares me too whole line is
scary it's definitely not what it's been
those could rely on Dalton no Dalton's
scary Dalton's towards the bottom of the
NFL in the NFL as far as quarterbacks
starting quarterbacks come on all these
young studs we got the league come on
Aaron Andy dogs clearly towards 28 to 32
in football if not lower than that yeah
and I think the big point is what you
said what is their offense tell me I
don't know what it is it's AJ green
running a go RAL right John Ross running
a go run to run by Mixon and then it's
all will throw another slant to AJ and
then OU will throw a screen to me you
know it's just there's no tying together
there's no theme there's nothing that I
go oh this is what they do you better
stop that or you're in trouble do it but
but there are some studs on this
football team it's one of the best
secondaries and the spor it is but yeah
I'm with you I think it's a seven and
nine type of season again the Browns you
look at weeks 1 through 10 the offenses
that they face so they start off against
Big Ben then the second week they go to
New Orleans and face Drew Brees
then they get Sam darn 'old then they go
to Oakland and face Gruden then they get
beat up with Baltimore then they face
the Chargers and Philip Rivers then
Jameis Winston's back and I have a
feeling they're gonna be good by that
point then they play Big Ben again
Patrick mahomes Matt Ryan yeah and I'm
gonna be honest I'm gonna say this right
now about the Browns I know everybody
out there is loved and Greg Williams and
they're going man he talks stuff and all
that stuff I'm just gonna be honest Greg
Williams had a safety playing 30 yards
off the line of scrimmage last year and
his blaming his roster I know that
people like Greg Williams especially
defenders that have played for him I
don't think he's that great of a
defensive coordinator tight ends go off
against Greg Williams all the time yeah
I just I think there's holes in his
defenses well I think that I'm looking
at miles Garrett and I just I just I
don't think he's gonna be as great
because of that no I mean yeah that was
a hint I'm fading you're miles Kerry
he's gonna be Defensive Player of the
Year let's just end that conversation
but but I understand the Greg Williams
thing is real okay I mean Greg Williams
is his defense excites people because it
can be they can be created blitzing and
create turnovers but it's not always
sound so that does concern me and yeah
the Browns offense you know it's good
again but there's just a lot of question
marks there I think the Browns are
improved football team don't get me
wrong I think they're like a I'm gonna
say a 5 and 11 to 6 and 10 type of
football team we
just have breaking news Sam Darnell is
officially going to be a week one
starter therefore the New York Jets he
is the youngest starter in NFL since
nineteen seven to twenty one in June
right crazy and he'll be on the
newly-formed Sims and left go show
coming out next Wednesday at 8 p.m. on
the VR app be there be there we took him
around the city to get him ready for his
first start the show's gonna be sick
any other thoughts on the AFC North
before we move on no but it's I mean
even one thing creams in the playoff we
do then one thing about the AFC North is
manda they got some some jimmies and
Jose I mean they just got some men in
that conference where I just go damn you
know every team is Harlow call those
Dunlap and Gino Lawson yeah exactly
perfect and they're secondary
Kirkpatrick all those guys and then
Cleveland Myles Garrett and their
offensive lines actually really good I
think really the reason is I'm all on
Cleveland they're coaching yeah get it I
think they got great players I need to
charge my computer it's gonna die out Oh
moving on AFC South two teams in the
playoffs out of this division last year
the Jacksonville Jaguars ten and six the
Tennessee Titans nine and seven Sims you
first how many playoff teams from this
division to love it laughs go
how many playoff teams from this
division to I was gonna have one if I
went with Miami he'll wear the same
teams give us your division winner let
me go okay Sims your first the
Jacksonville Jaguars mmm-hmm laughs go
your division winner the Houston Texans
Sims talk us through the Jaguars hold on
who we don't know who is other team is
oh you want to do the wild cards and ya
wanna know is wildcard team who's your
wild card oh you just wanna do that
okay yeah you'll sue the Jaguars first
well ya know cuz I want to see what my
wild card is I'm really okay who's your
wild card the first one is no no no yeah
who's the other team in the AFC South
that's getting in the playoffs all right
we already know one of them we didn't I
just start here the Jaguars see who's
your other one no but I'm saying the
other wild-card team we did it in the
last division didn't mean there's to it
if you have yeah I know what it is but I
got it the Houston Texans okay and lefke
the Jacksonville Jaguars
Tennessee Titans are not making the
playoffs so same thing as the north but
you guys are re other stuff scared the
crab take it away with the Jaguars
Jaguars are the best football team in
the sport they're the best defense one
of the best I've ever seen
don't know how many times I could say it
let me just say this right now miles
jack is going to be the best middle
linebacker in football this year
I mean Lefko knows because I text them
the other night as I was watching
Jacksonville film and holy crap
okay miles jack is on a mission and it's
gonna be a special year they are just
too talented of a football team even
with their lack of quarterback play I
don't think it's always gonna be pretty
they do have a tough schedule there's
definitely a little bit more of a
bull's-eye on their back but at the end
of the day I'm not just gonna doubt them
because of the quarterback they've
proven they can win despite him and they
can manage football games without him
and I just think with the additions the
old line and the receiving corps still
being good damn and Nate Hackett's
ability to call plays at the right time
and tie them together and make life easy
on Blake bortles yeah I'm going with the
Jags
so the Jaguars schedule when I looked at
it is a tale of two halves their first
half is really tough yes their second
half is actually quite easy the first
half the Jaguars that's the reason I
have the Jaguars getting to the playoffs
at nine and seven okay they start off at
the Giants right then against New
England yeah then home against Tennessee
who they lost to at home last year lost
through twice to last year then they go
to Arrowhead against Kansas City tough
place to the Jets first and then arrow
oh yeah I'm just this is a no specific
order these are just teams are playing
cool at Dallas against Houston and
Philly I mean they could lose a lot of
those games the ball doesn't bounce
their way good now on the second half
they get Buffalo they get Miami they get
Indianapolis twice second half is when
they're gonna go on their run right but
how they survived the first half is
going to tell me everything about
Jacksonville I mean I was lure Lee the
first two games might they go into they
could go anybody can go to it out
exactly I mean that was great analysis
well I mean that but they could also go
one-on-one
well it's just good they're there
they're a team that's they play and win
ugly so you know if yeah if it's one bad
mistake
a fumble whatever it may be that you
know Jalen Ramsay trips as he's covering
Odell Beckham jr. a baby Leonard
fournette getting banged up again on how
much they rely on him but the reason I'm
confident the Jaguars the offensive line
is improved the defense is still what it
is and they're one of the teams that can
still keep it simple and beat you
because they're better than ya I also
think that Blake is going to protect the
ball a little bit better this year and
then the wide receivers okay but I think
they're gonna lose some of the games
that they snuck away with less yeah that
would be my scare - what do you want to
say I'm just gonna get us going to the
Title III the one thing that I think is
just gonna hold Jacksonville back is
that simple in this though I will say
that it's short of me it's just why
every game is gonna be a one possession
game it's easier to play quarterback in
football now than ever before in the
history of this sport and when a
quarterback also knows the defense
you're gonna line up in all the time
that's why you see Jacksonville give up
big numbers to Brady or Garoppolo last
year or Big Ben in the divisional
playoff game cuz what is seen is when
you have a good quarterback and there's
a system that realizes oh we have a
system and they only play these two
defenses yeah
they don't care how good your frickin
players are it's just it's it's just
about them winning the division I do
yeah I think it's gonna be an ugly
winning of the division though like
you're kind of saying I wouldn't be
surprised if they're nine and seven and
the Houston Texans are nine and seven
they just want the you have the Texans
winning it I did I have them at 11 and 5
according to all the metrics the easiest
strength of schedule is the Houston
Texans this year remember they're
getting to play the AFC East which is
really nice and they're playing the NFC
East but those those bills dolphins Jets
games look really good in strength of
schedule they get the Patriots in week 1
which i think is when you want to play
the patriot I've seen this in the last
few years also look at the teams that
they play before the tough teams before
the Jaguars in week 7 they get the
Buffalo Bills before the Eagles in week
16 they get the New York Jets
I think Houston I'm taking that six
seven games span of the Shaun Watson and
I'm
spreading it out but more importantly
I'm looking at the defenders that not
everybody knows that are there the clown
ease the readers the Covington's and
then I'm adding a JJ Watt back I'm
adding a merciless back I'm adding a
honey badger back I like the coaches I'm
a little worried about the offensive
line but I think that the Shawn Watson's
that frickin special I really do
I do too I do I guess my reservation
with them would just be about how
special he is early on in the year can
he run around make some of those plays
the mine issues right because the
offensive line is it's it's spotty yeah
it definitely is bottom half of this
division I think you've kind of taken a
turn on Marcus Mariota over the last
three weeks watching preseason yeah it
definitely have it's just the way he's
throwing the football I don't care what
the stats look like it's the way it
looks uh it's it's been bad I mean it's
just been throws that are should be
easily completed in the NFL for a
quarterback of his stature and he's
missing them by wide margins so yes that
does concern me
I also say this Lafleur it's his first
year as a OC that's not always easy for
even a young smart guy like him and you
know yeah I mean Mike Vrabel he's a good
head coach I think everything's going in
the right direction with the Tennessee
Titans I just say let's not forget that
that defense was not special last year
Dean Pease is there to help them out so
that maybe that helps but that would be
concerning to me a little
I had Tennessee going eight and eight I
find all this divisions gonna be right
around there yeah look at the defense's
that Mariota is gonna have to face
before thereby this is what they better
figure out this offense quick Houston
who I just talked about yeah at
Jacksonville right Philadelphia right in
Buffalo the defense of Buffalo is gonna
be fine I'm having them lose all those
games cuz that offensive line ray then
Baltimore then in the Edit at the
Chargers and Miami's defense a weak ones
not gonna be a joke right right so
that's that's six of the seven defenses
yeah Mariota and that defense and
especially you talked about the lack of
interior offensive line okay Houston we
know what they got Jacksonville we know
what they got
Fletcher Cox Buffalo whatever Baltimore
right chart like come on yeah I just
think they're in for a rude awakening
they're gonna start slow yeah
but I think you're right it's gonna
start slow I'm gonna say they're uh yeah
six and ten seven and nine type of
football team I got a lot it's a
competitive competitive division and
yeah I don't think anyone's just gonna
run away with this thing me saying all
the teams that's understandable or is it
too much no I actually like it yeah I
mean I think it has to be to me just to
add my two cents of football experience
the start of the year is almost
everything in an NFL locker room you
know you got to think about it like this
losing one game you're ten games back in
baseball that's what it's worth you go
oh and two and somebody else I need your
visions too and oh twenty like being
twenty games back exactly right it's a
huge hole to fall into and coaches the
pressure the panic right oh and - oh
gosh we might not go to the playoffs
our coaches on the hot it all starts to
just roll downhill [ __ ] rolls downhill
and that's what happens you yeah before
we move on what do we expect from Andrew
Luck so um let me go through yeah I
think the trickiest part of their
schedules gonna be weeks three to five
at Philly against the Texans at New
England that's I'm just chalking that up
as three losses right there this is
what's incredible about the Colts and
why I'm excited about Frank Reich what
they did last year I kept saying they're
going into these fourth quarters with a
lead here is how historic that I see
last year in the last 27 years they were
the only team to lose at least seven
games they led at halftime so they led
seven games at halftime and lost her
they're the only team in 27 years to do
that
they're the only team in 20 years to
lead nine games into the fourth quarter
and finished fourth and 12 or worse talk
about predictability when they lined up
in 11 personnel no no excuse me they ran
a hundred percent of the time unless
they lined up an 11 personnel that's not
accurate
they ran okay that doesn't make sense
sounded like a good stat down I gotta
check that one that one sounded too
egregious I'm just saying their schedule
has gotten a lot easier when you look at
their schedule last year they ended up
playing really tough teams it's an
easier schedule right I actually have
the Colts though at 7 and 9 I have the
Colts exceeding their win total I
believe at 6 and a half
I think the Colts are gonna have a
pretty good year this year and surprise
some people I don't I think they're
gonna be a lot of games I mean they're
gonna be a pain in the butt because I do
think that Reich with the offense and
office lines better and I do think it's
still Andrew Luck I don't think he's
gonna be the Andrew Luck it's almost
down to him it really does I just look
at their overall roster still though and
just go damn how can they do it I mean I
think they're gonna be like a six and
ten type of team one more year I think
they they you know I just look at it
okay you know it's T Y Hilton's sure
I mean running back yeah it's okay but
there's questions yeah and then the
defense scares me I think that's all
that there is to it and the way they
like the 49ers pushed them around the
other day Alfred Morris was running
around them like he was Jim Brown at
their starters that were yeah it's just
it's just I just think there are a team
that's in total rebuild mode they got it
going in the right direction with the
right guy trust you more than I trust me
I don't know if that's true but whatever
moving on to the AFC West yep one team
out of this division last year the
Kansas City Chiefs ten and six you guys
both have both your wild cards already
done for the AFC so you both have one
team coming out of this division yeah
I'm guessing it's gonna be the same team
so do you want to just say it together
on three on three one two three Chargers
all right yes let me talk about him I
would like I would like that yeah III
just when I look at the AFC West you
know it's up for grabs certainly there's
no proven commodity there but I think
far in a way that the Los Angeles
Chargers have the most complete roster
in the division I think that's where I
look at it more than anything the
offensive line is gonna be better okay
and they got some depth actually I mean
the guys that they got in there starting
right now you know ohcome the Feeny kids
it's a young draft pick they had Pouncy
at center you know Michael Scofield not
a bad player Barksdale at right tackle
Scofield if he slips up for a slant will
be in there that's why they drafted him
in the second round last year so that
with Phillip Rivers Anthony Lin's run
game scheme that we've talked about
before and maybe the best complete
receiving corps in the sport and then
the defense come on
so what record do you got him home I
think it's gonna be like I don't think
anybody's just gonna run away with the
AFC this year like I think the one seed
might have the same record as the three
seed what's your record I'm gonna say
I'm gonna
I get one more look I have met 11 and
five I'm gonna say I was gonna go here's
the one five or not and says one thing
I'm not gonna do is bet too much on the
Chargers yeah because let's also be
realistic they're a team that should
have been the playoffs but they're a
team that didn't make the playoffs
because of themselves last year yeah
they had a kicker that couldn't make
anything that they chose yeah and I also
think that them being the only team in
the NFL that doesn't have an analytics
department like it just goes into a lot
of my thinking yeah okay they are the
only team in the league to play just two
top tens teams from last year that's a
Pittsburgh and the Rams so that blends
into that as well my number two team in
that division I'm tempted to go with the
Broncos but I have them at 7 and 9 I
have the Chiefs at 7 and 9 and I have
the Raiders at 5 and 11 that's where I
have that division I'll just go run
through mine really quick yeah Broncos
this is wild the Brock the at home
they're only favored to win by the
standard three in one game the Browns
Vegas is expectations the Browns are
very low and let the scuse me the
Broncos right I think that defense Case
Keenum playing safe obviously their
offensive line scares me I have only
good 7 & 9
I think they're gonna be average what
scares me about the Chiefs is Andy Reed
it not what it normally is it's that
Andy Reid has a philosophy he protects
the football and they don't turn the
ball over and that's how they win yeah
in the last two years the Chiefs won the
turnover battle in 20 of 32 games in
those 20 games were they won the
turnover battle the record was 18 and 2
which is incredible they're not gonna
win the turnover battle in a lot of
games this year they're going from Alex
Smith who protects the ball to patrick
mahomes who's gonna throw it away and
what scares me about the Chiefs is not
what that does to Patrick mahomes psyche
but how much more that bad Chiefs
defense is going to be on the field
defending a short field I think that
Chiefs defense is going to be Brett bad
I also think that the start of the
season is going to be awful for them at
Chargers at Pittsburgh Hosting Kyle
Shanahan and
francisco at denver hosting the jaguars
at new england did you hear what I just
said I did hear that that's edible
that's like a two and four one and five
maybe they win the Denver game and steal
one from San Francisco but that's one
that's two and four one and five is it
certainly can be so that's why I took
them down a peg yeah and Oakland I think
it's a great start for Gruden after the
Raider the Rams they get Cleveland they
get Seattle at home they get a trip to
Miami but the last few games are tough
and I just this Khalil Mac situation I
think is gonna hang over them the whole
year I have them at five and eleven yeah
and their defense scares me the Raiders
I just don't think it's a total of
complete roster yet the tackles can can
bother you the AFC West then I'll say
this what order do you have I mean it's
it's I think if you made me go down to
the order I would go chargers I think I
would go Broncos you would I think so
too I thought I was being a little crazy
no I'd probably go Chiefs three Raiders
four but it's so the same way it would
be this very interchangeable I mean
let's not forget Derek Carr is special
yes he can be special in fourth quarters
of football games and they are a veteran
team and that's typically start fast
right exactly right and really they
could start off four and one the
branches are similar that way yeah you
know Musgrave I do like the offense
there's weapons at receiver the
offensive line is better this year and
the defense like you said it's it's
certainly formidable I mean it really is
it's a very this is a very up for grabs
develop yeah it really is but I do feel
pretty confident that the Chargers are
the best football team in it Chiefs
you're not feeling Chiefs my big things
are really you hit on them I mean the
mahomes yeah they're gonna turn the ball
over a little bit more they're gonna
throw 70 yard touch they're gonna be
like man this is the most fun team to
watch in in football but yeah I think
there will be some bad interceptions and
then yes like we talked about a few
weeks ago like there's no difference
maker on their front seven dude the
Chicago Bears yeah second team yeah hung
up 21 points on them on their starters
and did whatever they want we talked
about member two weeks ago he said Chris
Jones was really the only guy that was
capable that he's disruptive in the
backfield he's the only guy I look at
you know in the in the secondary you
know it's just it's nothing special
there there's some solid
we don't know what our guy the Eric
Barry's gonna be like yet so yeah I just
can't hang my hat on this cheese I think
all of them are around like that six and
ten seven and nine I've an 11 I think
the Charger's will be like 11 and 5 or
10 and do a little bit more on the
Raiders yeah the Raiders I mean I think
what I just look at the Raiders - all
right again there's some young guys huh
you know some of the draft picks we
talked about on defense certainly
there's there's some positives there but
I think when you really break him down
again okay you know linebacker position
yeah okay
cornerback I mean I don't know I haven't
seen Gary and Conley yet at all I mean
so he doesn't he doesn't sometimes he
could practice I mean who are we gonna
go DRC Leon Hall rashon Melvin I just
don't know where you know and then
there's the the Carl Joseph's at safety
that still hasn't really opened up eyes
so I just don't see the defense being
able to make enough difference in place
to kind of help out what I think is
gonna be an offense that's can be
explosive at times so our AFC playoffs
yep pretty similar so yeah you both pick
the Patriots AFC North Sims pick the
Steelers to win it Ravens as the
wild-card you have the you have the
Ravens and the Steelers AFC South
Jaguars and techs and Sims you went
Texans and jaguars and then you both
pick the charge so we both have the same
playoffs we've just different mice you
wanna hear my seeding yeah let's here's
my seating is Steelers one Pats - oh
this is interesting Chargers three
jaguars for Ravens five Texans six mice
eating is Patriots one baltimore to
houston three chargers for steelers five
jaguars are the six seed sneaking in at
nine and so who's your three seed
Houston Houston in the Jags out of play
at AFC South match up in the wild-card
yes yes all right let's move on to the
NFC will come back and playoff picture
yeah later all right you want to say the
NFC East for last
I'm so happy you said that I think we
should save it for last all right so
let's start with the NFC you sure a
giant I'm gonna giggle it's better that
way NFC North Vikings ran away with this
division last year at 13 and three how
many teams we have coming out of this
division left go let me check your
account for us make sure yep NFC North
here
I made a playoff bracket so I'm like all
right who the hell would I pick here to
to also exciting your winner left go my
winner with a record of 12 and 4 is the
Minnesota Vikings Sims your winner the
Minnesota Vikings and then left go give
us your wild card
the Detroit just getting Green Bay bands
your wild card the Green Bay fighting
Aaron Rodgers talking to so defers Wow
okay Minnesota I have them going 7 and 1
at home this year I'm sorry I should
have done the records I didn't know that
was gonna do it I literally just did it
just to give my brain order ok um listen
you're better off the cuff' anyway ok
good so I have the Vikings doing really
well but listen to their road games this
year these are four of them at the
Eagles at the Rams at the Packers at the
Patriots I mean holy crap only those are
three teams they're gonna be fighting
with well the Packers they have to play
yeah let's go but Rams Eagles they could
be fighting for seeding no doubt um
schedule is not an easy schedule I mean
there's there's plenty of good football
teams down there to little nuggets and
then I'll let Sims take over they are a
team unlike the Colts that hold on to
their halftime leads they led 12 half
times last year they won 11 of them they
state you it's really hard to come back
on the Vikings and that's what happens
when you have that defense the other
side the quarterback this is an ode to
Kirk Cousins and it's also a reason why
I think they're gonna take a step
forward in the last two years Cousins
has had to face the toughest past
defenses out of any quarterback in the
NFL 13 top ten past defenses when he
faced them they were a 30 or a top 10
defense I think that we've seen Kirk
Cousins in a much tougher schedule
Washington for some reason always gets
one I think he's gonna take a step
forward
I see Minnesota it's all clicking right
now III can't disagree with that the one
thing that concerns me is just the
offensive line yeah right that's the
only thing really just the interior part
for Jones has been has been banged up uh
and that will be you know a factor
especially for an offense that is going
to I would believe under you know what
the hell is his name Phillip Filippo the
newbie filipova Lippo right and I like
that too because then you can't just
take schirmer's offense and get beads on
it no no one kind of knows right and
there's something to that might take
things from Shermer but he's gonna take
things from Frank Reich and Doug
Peterson and he's gonna also let's not
forget he was a pretty good offensive
coordinator himself before he met all
these other coaches in Cleveland yes
all right so he's going to add something
to that football team this year but like
I said only the interior all line is
really my only concern on their roster
do I wish they had a hair more depth on
their D line yeah
I do but I do think it's a little bit
better than years past you two enough to
where at least like Everson Griffin
doesn't get to play 85 percent of the
stuff right he can get a few sacks at
the end of the year instead of
disappearing like he has the last few
years cuz he's absolutely exhausted the
secondary special the linebackers are
special I do think it's a little bit of
a team on a mission with Kirk Cousins
having the right leadership guy in there
and let's not forget that Alvin cooks
going to be back and he would be
arguably their most explosive offensive
player when healthy so
yeah I'm with you the Viking schedule is
tough I don't think they're gonna like I
I don't want to say what's well I
haven't them winning the division I have
as the two seed can I say that is that
all right for now Aaron Rodgers has been
paid and you both have the Packers going
back to the playoffs this season they
went seven and nine last year yeah if
you look at the first seven games of the
Green Bay Packers the only really tough
team I see on there is the Vikings yeah
they start off with the Bears then the
Vikings they go to Washington back to
face Josh Allen in the bills at the
Lions San Francisco at home and then
it's a bye
they can go to that by five and one six
and oh I know that's a it's exactly
right I mean there's just it's just a I
mean Oh Detroit no pass rushers 49ers no
pass rushers Buffalo Bills no pass
rushers you know I just look at those
teams and when I look at those teams in
week four or five and six and I just go
damn Aaron Rodgers if you have those
type of teams he can beat you by himself
I don't even care if like the whole
receiving corps is out with like you
know the
West Nile virus yes so that's what would
scare me there the other thing is to is
look at some of the out of division
games they play they face the Jets who
we now know as a rookie quarterback yeah
they face the Cardinals in week 13 at
Seattle doesn't seem as hard this year
as it does other years they get Miami in
week 10 so there's a lot of other ones
and they get to face the rams after a
bye
which i think is really good I just I
have good expectations for I do and it's
Aaron Rodgers and I think he's gonna be
insane motivate I do too I mean just the
way he's yelling out his rookie
receivers he's been very vocal with his
leadership this year I think that's
what's changed for me
you know he's yeah I think he's turned
the corner of not worrying about you
know people's feelings he's gonna be
kind of to Tom Brady approach now like
yeah make us better or screw you and get
out of here and I think the defense and
the back end is going to be better with
gyre Alexander and the guy Josh Jackson
and getting involved in it I think
that's the big thing for me as a defense
yes I have some stats to show you how
great Rodgers is and how really bad the
defense has been let's go good stats
I love these nice lineup yeah the last
10 games that he's faced top 16 so this
is over the past two years they faced
top 16 defenses ten times in those games
Rodgers is 9 and 1 when they faced top 5
and lost vikings once right when they
faced top 5 defenses they're four and OH
so Rodgers has done his part to be the
defenses now when the Packers when
they're facing a an offense so the other
teams offense they faced 16 teams I'm
gonna try and figure this outside the
top 12 they're 14 and 2 so when they
didn't have to face a top 10 offense
like 14 and 2 right when they had to
face an offense in the top 12 they were
2 & 8 yeah so then it became Rogers
versus the other team's office right
what can he beat the Atlanta Falcons why
because the Atlanta Falcons are going up
and down the field the track race and
yes I need Aaron Rodgers to be the 12th
defender and now I think with Mohammed
Wilkerson and Kenny Clark and Mike
Daniels and all the athletes in the back
I think they're gonna be a little bit
better this year and more importantly
it's Mike Pettine not Dom Capers no Dom
Capers
in the first few weeks we always go wow
he's getting really creative and then at
the end of the year we'd be like he's
playing the same defense yes right he'd
like have an off season of like let me
try some yeah let me try these for
blitzes and then everybody I'll catch on
by week ten and kill them take us
through the bottom half of this division
laughs go bears and lions I have the
Bears at nine and seven yeah okay I have
a three seed it was very close they were
in my fighting for a wild-card spot I
think the third place in the division
third place in the division I think they
have a pretty soft opening schedule but
beyond the schedule I'm gonna kind of go
on this yeah from 2012 to 2016 there
have been eight quarterbacks that have
been drafted in the top ten seven of
them have improved in their second year
the only one that didn't was RG three
and we know that it was a special
circumstance I think that we're gonna
see growth intra Biscay I think that
Nagy's really gonna embolden that more I
think the Bears have also been one of
the most injured teams in the last two
years and I don't see that happening
again
I also think that in one score games
last year they were two and six that
usually regresses to the mean so like
games that are really close they always
end up going to 500 I think they're
gonna win more I see them at 9 and 7 how
do you see the typical a similar type of
thing I think Vic Fangio is gonna be
great yeah they're they're gonna be a
pain in the butt no I think really the
only thing that holds them back is that
they're they're young they're new they
get a new head coach you know learning
how to win in the NFL is a real thing
it's like real it's not like oh and I've
had friends tell me so what are these
guys they don't need to learn how to win
they but what is this is they were in
high school in college yeah I'm sorry
this is a different world than those
sport those leaks the NFL comes down to
one play every game and if your
quarterback or somebody young messes
that up you lose and you look back at
the game and you go damn we played so
well why don't we lose oh this cuz our
corner fell down on third and 15 and
they went for an 80 yard touchdown or or
our quarterback didn't know how to
manage a situation that's what scares me
about them I really think this is a team
that's on the rise on the rise in a
hurry there's really I mean you you look
at what they've done we know their front
seven you know I like them I got a lot
of man
Russia's done a lot of guys there's
great depth we haven't even seen ro Quan
Smith the fuller kid is one of the best
corners in the sport and they have a
very good safety do like Adrian Amos is
real good and any play Eddie Jackson is
good as well yeah I mean a muls pops
does he he pops he's pops more than I
know more than I gave him credit for to
last year Matthew Stafford and the Lions
missing the playoffs for the second
straight year yeah I have them finished
in seven and nine I think it's gonna be
kind of a rough year for them the second
half of their schedule they play the
toughest defenses in the NFL compared to
any other team and when you also factor
in this they have to go week 15 to
Buffalo and week 17 to Green Bay this is
a Detroit Lions team that has to go and
play in cold weather yeah and I think
that's a factor for it too I think that
Matt Stafford is gonna be Matt Stafford
I actually see him taking a step back
this year I think that Matt Patricia is
gonna at the end of the year look at Jim
Bob cooter and go I think I want my own
guy yeah that could bury pass how I see
the Lions season play there's too many
questions I have about the Lions in
general Matt's average certainly not one
of them but I still question the old
line in the run game
it hasn't looked anything special this
preseason like beyond that I know
so that's scary to me right I do still
think they're dangerous cuz of Stafford
and his ability to make unreal plays but
I also will say this like the defense
scares me too just because it's
different than anything they've done and
there's gonna be a lot more I think
mentally on there's gonna be an
adjustment period of not only Colossus
never played a defense like not really
not like this type of thing this is
gonna be more multiple more three-four
type rules it's so they they're so
rooted in four three and then you think
about like Jared Davis like is there a
linebacker that's worse for Patricia's
defense no he'll be okay I think so I do
I just thought he wanted the big Donte
Hightower you know to a degree they've
always err on the more big type of
middle linebackers but Jared Davis is
not small remember I mean if I'm if I'm
correct I think he's like 238 238 6 1
238
I am sick I saw his butt once in a tight
pair of pants and look Detroit fans get
upset because I don't think people ever
give Detroit love we love Matt Stafford
we do respect Darius Leigh you've always
liked Jared Davis Ezekiel anticipation
Robinson he Sean Robinson's always been
a fan I like the receiving core I don't
see I don't know what carry-on johnson
is yet but for me it really came down to
the lines yeah and they've been pushed
around on both sides this preseason and
it just hasn't looked good no it has not
and yeah I'm with you I just there's
something about the the Lions that do
not jump off to me when I evaluate them
and see South pull up your notes up NFC
South gosh
so three teams out of this division last
year Saints Panthers Falcons all in the
playoffs Sims how many teams this year
to left go to where this is crazy Sims
give us your division winner the Saints
left go your division winner
the Falcons Sims your wild-card team the
Falcon oh my gosh
laughs go your wildcard team you Bucks
know those things
yeah just reversed all right let's uh
let's talk Saints first because this is
great you've been jacked up about the
Saints for probably two months now yeah
I mean two years yeah convincing
yourself of this all summer I really
have you're right about that and I mean
first of all I think the first thing you
have to talk I'll let left go talk about
the schedule more but the scattered what
kind of wreck you think for the Saints I
mean I don't think again the NFC is too
tough yeah so where I got about ten and
six I would be like 11 and 512 and for
type of football team the one thing
that's really encouraging to me more
than anything is the start of their
schedule which I know you're gonna get
to in a second but it's nice to be five
and OH heading into yeah right even
though they're not even playing their
best football they could be four and one
or three and two and yes oh okay but I
do think the defense is pretty legit I
think it came around as the year went on
last year Marcus Davenport their
first-round pick he's just getting
involved into the flow here he will be a
difference maker their secondary is
legit I mean Marshawn Lattimore is in
the conversation
one of the five best cover corners in
football he can have an island named
after him the Kenny Crawley's good ken
Crawley is very good on the other side
and they got eagles Nickelback Patrick
Robinson this offseason so they have
another guy to go along with PJ Williams
who's not bad himself and they have some
decent safety play as well so that's the
that's the defense and the defense of
course is the big question because what
what's there to question about the
offense I mean it's this is Sean Payton
and Drew Brees it's always phenomenal
and it's one of the best offensive lines
in football if not the best that's how
good it is it's definitely in the
conversation with the Dallas Cowboys
that's how awesome this offensive line
is and hey it's still Sean Payton Drew
Brees Michael Thomas Teddy Ginn Cameron
Meredith sounds like he's going to come
around yeah okay and they got Ben Watson
still it tied in there's enough there to
member me to go with the coaching along
with it and I know the Saints will
always be physical because Sean Payton's
a psycho yes I like them so I'm gonna
give you the good thing about the same
schedule and I'm gonna give you the bad
thing and the bad thing is the reason
why the Falcons were in the division the
good thing is those first five games
yeah
Tampa no Jameis Browns no gelling at
Atlanta's the hard one yeah at the
Giants Washington that could be 500 for
the Saints that's how good the Saints
are then after week eight man it hits ya
here is a five-game stretch after we
gave at Minnesota hosting the Rams at
Cincinnati which is a physical team
after playing the Vikings home against
Philadelphia home against Atlanta and
you missed Baltimore right after the bye
yeah I mean yeah you're right at
Baltimore Baltimore at Minnesota yeah
you're right
thank you for making it harder for them
I also want to add this week's 12
through 15 so that's the Atlanta game
then thirteen is at the cowboys then
they play at the Bucs then at the
Panthers so one they have three games on
the road where they're going to Dallas
Florida Carolina the Saints have three
of those games in primetime I know
that's the what I that's the first thing
that jumped out to me they're like oh
and three on the road in prime time
games since 2016 hmm but you have
three prime time games in a four-week
span where you're on a three-game road
trip I just see from week seven to week
15 of them by the way they play the
Steelers in week 16 right they could
start off really fast
I see the Saints kind of getting beaten
down from that and that's what scared me
and that's why I didn't have them win
the division they've a really hard
schedule it's very tough that second
half of the year let's talk Falcons you
picked them to win the division here
laughs cow I do so after they play
Philadelphia it's not the easiest
schedule but five of their next six
games are at home in that Stadium I
think they're gonna get the win in
Philadelphia which is why I like that
and also I do think that sarkeesian's
offense got a lot better as the season
went on I'm gonna say this right now
the Falcons with a better team in that
playoff game that the Eagles won they
had the ball down five with a minute 20
left like getting ready to go into the
red zone Ivan the Falcons are just a
good team I like the fact that they have
so many home games in the beginning of
their schedule and I think that they
match up well with the Saints I think
they match up well with all the guys in
their division and I think that people
are sleeping on how good the defense is
and I think that sarkeesian's gonna
figure it out a little bit better this
year and I think Matt Ryan's hit maybe
the best year of his career last year I
think it continues I have them at an 11
and 5 divisional winner yeah right I
mean I'm putting him in the wild-card
I'm putting him in the number six seed
so you know that so I think it's gonna
be a ten and six type of team right that
gets in I think there could be other
teams that are ten and six this year in
the NFC that don't get in the playoffs
like that's how good the NSC is I mean
it hurt me did not put the Carolina
Panthers in just to say that right off
the bat but man that did the Falcons are
so talented there's no doubt about that
I mean it's one of the most talented
rosters in football the one thing that
does scare me about them is the coaching
though absolutely no like Sarkisian it
could be better but it could be worse
yeah like I have no nothing to back it I
mean I know I know you don't and I don't
have anything to back it up to say why
it's really gonna be worse yes only
other than that we saw what he did last
year and then teams can study him a
little bit but did yet did he grow is
there more to it other thing that scares
me about that
as talented as their defenses okay it's
not as talented as Jacksonville okay if
some of those right I know of course but
it's that same thing that scares me good
quarterbacks good systems oh you're
gonna play the same two defenses all
game long that's great
that scares me that scares me this year
with the Eagles the Panthers the Saints
the Steelers has for their first five
games to go damn that's quarterback play
and decent offensive coordinators across
the board that are gonna go wait they're
just gonna play these two defenses all
the time
so that scares me but there's still just
too talented for me to them to count
them out they really are I mean Matt
Ryan's still a baller yeah I know people
get bad and say on that and he's not a
top-five quarterback whatever he's still
really awesome and he can take them to
the Super Bowl
Tara MacLean scared me on the interior
part of their D line I know I've told
you that I think I told you the other
day he has gotten blown back a few times
there in the run game which is scary to
me
but really other than that they got
freak shows all over this I think so -
yeah take us through the bottom of this
division left go
I have Carolina at around seven and nine
I think they have a very tough start for
their offensive line only thing that
stopped me from putting them in the pile
offensive line I mean just the start of
their schedule and the way it looked so
remember they don't have Thomas Davis to
start the year either which i think is
huge so their offensive line is gonna
face Dallas I think that's crazy pass
rusher 80 at Atlanta and then Cincinnati
who we just saw Geno Atkins so like that
offensive line right off the bat we're
gonna see their ending is Saints Falcon
Saints so like you're out of the
playoffs like that's what's gonna happen
right there and they're non divisional
away games
think about the quarterbacks that they
have to face on the road Carson Wentz
Matt Stafford Ben Roethlisberger and
Alex Smith is not gonna mess the game up
no you're gonna have to play off a
complete game against Washington and I
mean that defense is gonna give a
Carolina problems to with a lead yeah at
halftime in the last five years Carolina
when they're leading is 45 and eight hmm
when they're tied or losing they're done
nine twenty four and one yeah they get
away from what they can want to do the
weapons of microcosm
of the Panthers and it's a microcosm of
Cam Newton and because of who they're
playing in the beginning of the year I
think they're gonna start off slow and
hope the wheels are gonna fall off
I have them going 7 & 9 Tampa Bay I have
it 4 & 2
I mean their first games without label 4
and 12 their first three games without
Jameis first three of their first four
it couldn't be worse at Saints Eagles
Steelers like loss loss loss and I think
they have they also have the toughest
conferences to play they're playing the
the NFC East and the AFC North yeah so I
I just see Tampa Bay four and twelve
Dirk cutters fired Jameis Winston we're
sitting there going oh wow they got four
wins of his last yeah that's I I mean I
I'm gonna say this first it hurt me more
than anybody other team did not put
Carolina in the playoffs
I was really my heart was trying to find
ways to figure out how I want to put
them in but I said don't listen to the
heart and this one let's go with the
brain it slightly has more brain power
than your heart like that analysis
brought to you by dr. Sims I think this
is what scares me
I do the office is gonna be better with
the Carolina brain has slightly more
brain power than the heart yes that's
gonna be on a t-shirt no yep that should
be um I think that the Carolina Panthers
will not be really pushed around by
anybody especially on the defensive side
of the ball like their defense is still
really yes no I do worry about like you
know pass rushers that can disrupt the
game off the edge with them you know
Julius Peppers is good but it's nothing
special Marriott it Mariel Addison all
good all right but I'm not gonna go bow
secondary we're about the same thing
secondary the same thing you know I like
James Bradbury but there's no difference
maker and the back end of that secondary
Dante Jackson started last week and he
looked very good you know my friend from
LSU yeah of course missile is almost
like Adams is gonna be slow he'll be the
starting corner on the other side I know
Mike Adams is still chugging along and
they play him in a very important role
still Kiki's amazing still at least they
have Shaq Thompson and you've been
impressed with him I have but I think at
the end of the day lack of just overall
difference-makers on
defense and the offense has giving me
glimmers of hope but I'm not gonna just
base that all on the preseason games
doing thoughts on Tampa before we go to
the West yeah I mean Tampa Jameis
Winston's maybe had the best preseason
of any quarterback in football I just
want to start it right there it's been
that special and it's a shame because
he's gonna waste it away the start of
the schedule like you said is too scary
I mean even with him back Oh back at
Chicago week four they can be very
easily Owen for I do think they're gonna
be a better football team I do - I think
v2v is gonna come in there in the second
half just Winston's gonna find his
stride yeah it's just it's just too
little too late exactly right now I see
the Bucks season they've kind of built
themselves up on defense to become
physical the secondaries got some
athletes and we know those linebackers
can run but it's another team that just
hasn't proven they can win or know how
to win their hands situational football
moving on to the NFC West last year the
Rams win this division 11 and five the
Seahawks came let's go only has one team
in the playoffs so do you so we have
what we each have one team in the West
yeah one team in the east
left go give us your division when
you're here the Los Angeles rooms I mean
this is an easy one yes the Rams take it
away okay I mean the rims it's one of
the most talented rosters in the sport
only thing that they can ruin the Rams
season is injury and I know that can
stand tall for anybody but they are a
very top-heavy football team we've
enough teams figure out Sean mcveigh's
office yes which I don't expect that to
happen no because it's not an offense
that really gets figured no he's gonna
more figure out your defense and come up
with a game plan that's you're gonna go
what I'm Angie D no team has bet had
better injury fortune in the last two
years in the rim no doubt about that are
the opposite of the Bears where I have
been pretty much unscathed for two years
right got a fairly easy start of the
schedule yeah let me tell you this this
is this is where the Rams will either be
a team with a bi right or a team that
wins their division and gets in weeks
three through ten mm-hmm they play the
Chargers and Minnesota right there then
they go on the road for three straight
games Seattle Denver San Francisco and
then then they face Aaron Rodgers
at home so for me oh and then by the way
they play at the Saints and then home
against Seattle that stretch three
through ten will determine whether they
win at 10:00 and 6:00 where I have them
or going 12 and for 13 and 3 and getting
a bye
but I think that they're gonna stumble a
lot in there I think it's a lot of tough
teams it's extremely tough teams and I
am NOT one to sit here and tell you that
I'm sold on Jared God by any stretch of
the imagination the NFC West who's your
number 2 team I would probably I'm
probably still gonna go to Seattle I in
Seattle Nate Nate I have Seattle and San
Francisco both finishing 8th and 8 yeah
I think Seattle's gonna start this year
3 and 1 and we're gonna go the Legion of
whom is gone at Denver at Chicago at
Arizona three of their first four games
Dallas is in there too it gets a little
bit harder but I think that Seattle they
have Pete Carroll they have Russell
Wilson and I know that this Michael
Dixon kid this punter they have special
teams yeah and Sebastian like I think
that they can find ways to win games
San Francisco starts off everyone over
there
yeah the wings from last night still yes
I think that the reason I want to pick
San Francisco is because when Kyle goes
into a second year with a quarterback
it's always better it's in every single
one it's every year but I look at their
schedule and I'm like man these are
these are four of their first six games
on the road at Minnesota at Kansas City
at the Chargers at Green Bay yeah I
think that the the Niners are gonna
start off two and six something like
that and I think they gonna end up
finishing the year like eight and eight
they finish six and two pretty much how
they did that year that's how I would do
those two - yeah I think so
I think Seattle's gonna be in the mix of
things all year I would say they ended
up about eight and eight nine and seven
on the outside looking in I think
there's a lot of people like that's
that's whale about I think they're there
over unders a 10-8 - yeah I mean yeah
they're still gonna be a handful like
you said I don't disagree with anything
you said there and then also you're the
49ers I would say there are seven and
nine football team I think
they're gonna have to score 30-plus
points a game to win and I just that's a
lot to ask of even Kyle Shanahan and
Jimmy Garoppolo I don't know if they're
capable of that so that would scare me
too
the other thing too would with the Rams
damn they got a lot of good football
players yes I mean it's just they're
they're they're a force to be reckoned
with but III do yeah I worry about Jared
Goff there and you don't even forgot to
say that I wanted to say this about my
Chargers argument I'm sorry to change
divisions the Chargers have nine home
games this year
which is amazing because they're one of
their world games is the Rams so it's
great that's one less we could travel
but yeah I do I think the Rams are
clear-cut the class of this division and
I don't I think they're a step above
everybody in what's really unfortunate
for the Arizona Cardinals I of them at
three and thirteen Seattle's over/under
is 8 so that I have them right around
that Arizona in a year where they were
gonna be rebuilding anyway has the
hardest strength of schedule in the NFL
these are their away games just throw
away games
Vikings Packers Falcons Chargers Chiefs
and then in division Rams Seahawks all
those games are on the road I'm not
putting Josh Rosen into that and I just
think it's that offensive line is a mess
even though you know what look they did
go and get Pugh and they got Andre Smith
it's been better and I you know that I
just I just don't trust them as a team
at all and their last no I I'm a rule 2
there it's a total regime change right
offensively defensively you know it's
it's a team that went from the blitzberg
scheme to now it's going to the Carolina
Panthers scheme all of that yeah I'm
with you
there's too many questions there as well
I mean if there's one team I'm worried
right now who's gonna prove me wrong
yeah I don't know why
well they've David Johnson clicks the
defense with Patrick Peterson they
played better than I have expected in
the preseason they really have and yes I
mean Mike McCoy back to just being the
total offensive coordinator and not
having to worry about being a few teams
from the NFC West yeah I'm just kidding
no definitely not
no are we ready for the final division
oh yeah all right gentlemen last year
the and I think we picked the same team
here the Philadelphia Eagles thirteen
and three coming into the
season as defending champions next up in
this division last year the Dallas
cardigan defending Super Bowl champions
who was that the Philadelphia Eagles you
good
alright by the way I am I am I'm just
gonna say this about
you're officially a Giants fan no no I'm
gonna say this about the Eagles and
being a Superbowl champion I thought
about this the other day
everyone says aren't you ready to move
on to the other season I will move on
Thursday night when they play the Falcon
right when that happens we're on the new
seasons yeah but I'm trying to soak up
every freaking second you should this is
what I would tell the Lions fans and
Browns fans everyone that Vikings fans
haven't won you want to enjoy every
moment and I'm just saying that same
over time defending Super Bowl champions
Philadelphia Eagles Thank You Sims who
do you have winning the NFC East the
Dallas Cowboys let go who do you have
winning the NFC East Dallas Cowboys are
you [ __ ] kidding well you know what I
mean this is what happens when you spend
any work together when you're my worry
Jeff well did you think that we were on
the same page because I've heard you
type and the Eagles I have the Eagles as
one where you weren't going the Eagles
and I heard you talking about the
Cowboys so that's who I thought it but
you know I think what is unbelievable I
thought you were going the Giants I know
I just can't do it I can't did God we
have the same teams in the AFC and the
NFC and we did not talk to each other at
is no surprise though this is the left
oh look I thought we did a value
different I thought if anything was
gonna be different it was gonna be
damage e's sure I thought I was going
crazy can doubt with the Giants man good
for you I couldn't do it no Cowboys
seven weeks or insane exactly right go
Cowboys first okay Cowboys first okay
first of all hey the Cowboys Wow
their defense is one of the pleasant
surprises of football to me in the
preseason and the fact that Chris
Rashard there is that in the past game
defensive coordinator added with Rod
Marinelli is it really a big boost for
me but I think what I'm so impressed by
is the plethora of defensive linemen
they have I mean it's a plethora it's
unbelievable it's almost like your
Eagles it's just like their their second
team G line you go damn they could be
starting that case
honey I look at their depth chart and
I'm like Malik Collins is like listed
here as tenth he might not make the
rosters unbelievable that's what I mean
so they were gonna have waves of people
coming at you Jaylon Smith has looked
good Sean Lee we know what he is but the
secondary I think is what really has
impressed me Byron Jones that was the
proper move to put him in a corner yeah
that's what he did in college
shidou bo was a yes right Jordan Lewis
who's not even their starting nickel
he's are starting dime because Anthony
Brown's they're starting nickel and
Xavier woods is hurt right now so
they're gonna have to figure out what
they want to do with that other safety
position but Heath is a good player too
but my only fear for the Cowboys is yeah
when dak has to throw yeah I just the
reason I went with them mm-hmm
this offensive line is special and we'll
see if it can be healthy the whole year
after all those injuries last year I
hope Tyron Smith's back doesn't act up
and all that but a healthy and focused
Zeke yeah without the suspension looming
I think it's gonna make dak a better
player obviously and I don't think the
wide receivers are really that bad like
I know they're they might be the worst
why receiving core though in the NFI I
don't know about that I don't know I
mean I'd have to look at a little bit
longer going Hearns michael Gallup Cole
Beasley in the slot yeah I mean it's a
lot of solid I don't see it if I see the
the Cowboys pounding people all year and
then their defensive line getting to get
after the other opposing quarterback in
the second half right and I see them one
in ten and six III would say they're
somewhere in that line I mean I think
there's enough there in their pass game
for me to go okay they're gonna keep
people honest and then we're gonna throw
the ball to Zeke Moore well I I think
that is going to be part of their
process that's what I'm hoping
I mean they've talked about it a little
openly so that makes me suggest Amin
that suggestion makes me believe only
averages like this what's crazy about
Zeke he averages 2.3 targets per game
yeah not even catches he can catch the
play well Le'Veon Bell David Johnson
these guys are at like seven targets
yeah Zeke needs to get the ball more in
the passing yeah he's too dangerous not
to get the ball in his hands hold on
Josh one more second and the other guy
that were forgetting and I think they're
Lake Jarvis well no I think they're
gonna put we're gonna see Tavon Austin
play a role down
ever seen I do I just think that they
made a trade for him he's lying in the
weeds and this is the guy you're gonna
see come down and come out I mean in
third down he might be Darren Sproles
this year I think we got to get stopped
thinking about him as just a wide
receiver I think he can they can play
that role and I think because they don't
do a lot on offense that they'll find
little cute ways to get him the ball I
have the Eagles going 9 and 7 I have
them splitting with Washington I have
them splitting with Dallas they have to
play Jacksonville in London which I'm
marking that up as an L because I think
Jacksonville is used to playing in
London I think it's a tough team to play
in London also they have to go to New
Orleans I think they're gonna lose this
Atlanta game and I think that Minnesota
comes in there's a lot of talent
I mean Tampa we too could be a trap no
way yeah without Jameis I I just look at
that and go as much ggressive as you
guys are on defense you're gonna leave
some of those guys man-to-man and just
my really point it's gonna be so [ __ ]
hot down there that they're gonna go wow
I didn't even that's where I thought up
Tampa as week - I just they're gonna
walk out in pregame ago why this Eagle
season's gonna be really frustrating so
I I don't know I'm at nine and seven I
think that they're a really good team
either they can fight and the true thing
is is Carson Wentz's Carson Wentz they
can win the division and fortunately
that's what it's gonna have to be I'm
done yeah yeah Sean Jeffrey injury that
you know what would you know what that
issue or the wide receivers is Jason
Peters gonna play for real like we don't
know that you know is Jason Kelsey gonna
be able to play the entire year Carson
one's gonna play yes all those things
it's really tough the honesty's brutal
it's really brutal and I can't believe
it but I yeah I let the Eagles out too I
have in third place the New York Giants
yeah I have them starting out one in
three and then finishing eighth and
eight I listened to the first seven
weeks of this these are the the I'm
gonna break it down to Home & Away
the who they face at home Jacksonville
New Orleans and Philadelphia could all
be losses here's the key egg here's how
they face on the road Dallas Carolina
Atlanta Houston yeah they could go Owen
seven
I know it's like if you play all the
really easy teams at the end yeah I mean
it's why I couldn't pick them if it's
really that as much as I like their
roster and the coaching changes and some
of the stars they have on their football
team I look at some of those teams they
play there and I go yeah I just can't
this point of the year I can't hang my
hat on the Giants yet yeah I get they
gotta prove to me that they can win some
of these physical tough close football
games against some of the most
physically tough football teams in the
sport I think that's where I look at it
and yes I look at it a little bit and
the factor of I'm certainly looking at
Eli Manning I mean there's no doubt you
like Manning's the biggest question mark
on the Giants and the defense's that
they have to face he has to make he has
to make the rows and he's gonna have
people around him making those throws
yes I mean the Jaguars Cowboys Texans
first three weeks you couldn't pick
three defensive lines who want to rip
quarterbacks heads off more than those
three right there I have Washington
starting the season to a no I even a few
times convince myself to go three and oh
and upset that team number three I can't
remember who it is I'll tell you right
now I'm pulling it up but I have them
finishing seven back Green Bay I could
see them beaten Aaron Rodgers in
Washington but I think that they
finished seven and nine I really wanted
Washington to find a way to make the
playoffs just from like I think they're
an interesting team I just think that
the Alex Smith stuff they play they play
a lot of tough defenses that oh you're
not gonna feel comfortable throwing it
deep then we're just gonna sit
underneath and we're gonna injure all
these often injured guys yeah I can't
believe you think the Cowboys III just
the East is so good and we could we
could be totally wrong about this vision
I mean that's that's the best thing
about it the Washington early schedule
you're right is certainly that I looked
at and go damn it they're gonna be too
and oh I would expect I expect them to
be to know but I also just think of Alex
Smith you know Jay Gruden's offense Jay
is not as creative as the McVeigh's in
the Shanahan's of the world no you know
the receivers Chris Thompson we don't
know if it'll be totally 100% I'm
hearing good things Josh Johnson still
an unproven commodity as far as the the
wide receiver position goes so there's a
lot of potential but I guess I have
question marks too I think the defense
is gonna be a pain in the ass
really do ya but I'm with you I know
there's just something about the
Redskins that I think this throws me off
a little bit more of a gut feeling but
the leadership at the quarterback
position what is Miami's over/under
Miami's over/under is 6.5 so here are
I'm gonna do this really quick these are
my six teams that I think I would take
the over on this year
Patriots 11 right Jets 6 Miami was it
six 6.5 I shouldn't do that okay get rid
of the Jets Patriots 11 Miami 6.5 Ravens
over/under is 8 that one I'm really
confident young Colts six-and-a-half I
like a lot and Minnesota 1000 yeah if I
was gonna bet those will be the ones I
would do all right let's go give us your
NFC playoff picture before we do all the
ranked you boy yeah so how are you
seeding the playoffs the 1 seed is
Minnesota the 2 seed is Atlanta the 3
seed are the Cowboys the 4 seed is the
Rams yeah my dad's calling really yeah
the 5 seed is the Packers and the 6 seed
is the Saints all right Sam's and give
us your NFC playoff picture and I have
the the Bears and Eagles just missing
okay I'm gonna go the one seat is the
Saints yep the 2 seed is the Vikings the
3 seed as the Los Angeles Rams the 4
seed is the Dallas Cowboys the Green Bay
Packers number 5 and the Falcons are 6
cool all right let's do some awards and
then we'll get the Super Bowl oh yeah
I'm excited
all right I hope everybody's enjoying
this long podcast but I'm enjoying it
I'm having a great time good all right
first up let's do uh let's say the MVP
and I have to play a player of the year
for last so first thing we're gonna do
here is Offensive Rookie of the Year Oh
Offensive Rookie of the Year left go go
first I was very tempted to say Michael
Dixon the putter from the Seahawks I
think that there is going to be a
campaign people are gonna talk about it
my pick for Offensive Rookie of the Year
is Royce Freeman
running back Denver Broncos I think they
have a surprising seven a nine eight and
eight year and I think he's gonna be up
there towards the the leaders and
rushing okay Ziggler exactly sometimes
the most obvious one is the I
overthought a lot of these I just yeah
he's just too special for me not to pick
up trust me I looked at it and was like
damn let me see if I can pick somebody
else but say Kwan I just can't do it
Defensive Rookie of the Year Sims your
first I'm going with a guy that we
haven't even seen play ball yet ro Quan
Smith really I just think in the middle
of that defense it's made for a guy like
him this is gonna be Patrick Willis jr.
for Vic Fangio and the amount of big
guys they have in front of him is just
gonna give him free run like it Georgia
to use his unbelievable explosive
ability just to tackle every but it's
what he is he's a ball hawk so yeah I'm
gonna go with him laugh go I think
Defensive Rookie of the Year it's
important to find teams that are
underestimated and that when they get
better they go who's new hmm that guy
I've a the defensive rookie there's
gonna be Minka Fitzpatrick I then the
Dolphins have a good year they look
around the roster and go and I also
think he's gonna get a lot of
interceptions you either need
interceptions or sacks in sims's case
he's going tackles
I think Minka gets Defensive Rookie of
the Year yeah minko was definitely on my
short list as well and I think after if
you but if I went farther past Minka the
next guy that I thought about was Mike
Hughes and Minnesota then you know
because he's gonna be the rookie who's
he looks like he's made a ton of playing
time and they're gonna want to try to
test him out in the slot and I think
he's gonna have someone waiting for him
tell you what lenka kid looks great in
the Jersey he does I mean he's great
acid legs great ass and legs pads look
nice yes
alright next up here Defensive Player of
the Year Sims already told us who he was
picking for this award on last week's
podcast blow up our content schedule
Sims who you got miles Garrett yes I
think he's the best player in defense
this year can I join the squad no oh I
was stuck between two people he's got a
doozy one that he said was going to be
the best linebacker the NFL yeah that's
a good pick Myles check okay but I'm
gonna go with Yannick and gawk way
terms baby I think that Yannick and gawk
way is going to be the free rusher
and I think he's gonna be I think
Yannick and gawk way is gonna finish the
year with 16 and a half 17 sacks for the
best defense the NFL it needs you need
credit for it
I think Yannick is gonna be my defensive
MVP yeah I I listen that's that's hard I
thought you're gonna say jaylen Ramsey
because Jalen Ramsey with some of these
offenses they play to like if he shuts
down Odell Beckham jr. a weak one right
it's just gonna start the campaign right
they're really good instead I think
Yannick it could do that to he's gonna
get four and a half sacks and Eric
flowers all right this is so before we
get there right now like that it's gonna
be the big game so my guy can launch his
campaign to be that exactly before we
get to NFL MVP
this is assumes in left go award the F
to play up Player of the Year we're
gonna have groups of people Travis and
player alright so Sims you can go first
flexor Cox Stefan to it Wow no I went
Fletcher [ __ ] okay but what's really
funny is when you said that I go he
thinks I'm thinking Stefan - oh you did
think that I'm gonna Fletcher Cox yeah
good guess he's it's you're not bad with
that one yeah I'm gonna just go with
Stefan - it just - I didn't want to go
Aaron Donald or Fletcher Cox so I wanted
to do something different and I think
Stefan to it because you guys heard me
wax so poetically about him the last few
weeks I had to do it and I do I think
he's one of I think he's in that
conversation when healthy with a
Fletcher Cox as that bigger defensive
tackle overpowering type and he's a
hundred percent healthy healthy this
year that's why I go with it left go
we're moving on to NFL MVP take us first
I think the NFL MVP will be Aaron
Rodgers that's my pick I think Aaron
Rodgers comes out here has like a 45 and
seven season I think he's gonna throw
like 8 to 12 touchdowns to Jimmy Graham
I think Davante Adams has a huge year I
think the Packers make it to the
playoffs and I think that all the other
teams have people competing you know
when Big Ben gets up there well what
about Antonio Brown the Vikings the
Jaguars defense you know there's always
someone else Aaron the people don't know
about how good Davante Adams is yet I
think Aaron gets a lot of the credit for
it I'm gonna there you spoke in such
hushed tones
well I'm realizing when I talk like this
it really sounds great professional Sims
your MVP what come on nice my time with
this a word you know I'm picking Tom
Brady Aaron Rodgers this is unbelievable
yeah I'm going Aaron Rodgers I'll sell
you my backups were Big Ben Brees and
then Russell Wilson those are the next
guys I went down the list but yes Aaron
Rodgers to me you know again there's you
know no great secondaries he has to play
early on in the year other than the
Minnesota Vikings and I just think that
they're they're a team and he's a guy
that's on a mission I do think that me
I'm hoping their office is gonna have a
few wrinkles into this year I've talked
about it in the off season
Joe Phil's oh I hope so but man he's
still in the prime of his career and I
think he's the best player in the sport
still Joe Philbin kind of looks like a
q-tip three weeks ago I did this without
like looking and offensive player of the
year which is also a word yeah I'm gonna
go that's why I was gonna pick because
we both had Dallas they lead the NFL I'm
gonna do the sportsmanship award also
last year I'm going with Jalen Ramsey
sportsmanship of the year I'd be good
all right last thing we got to do on
this podcast before we wrap up we're
gonna go through the whole playoff
picture we're gonna get to your Super
Bowl matchups and then we'll talk about
your Super Bowl prediction so I think
what I want to do here is I want to have
you talk me through your playoffs get to
your Super Bowl matchup Wow you tie FCN
NFC yeah then you don't have to go game
by game but just give us okay or go game
by game give us an idea of what goes on
Sims then we'll go to you for your
playoff how it unfolds and then we'll
talk Super Bowl sorry go ahead
so hold on you have the seeds right I do
have to see yes so AFC playoffs
let's do NFC AFC per se do the wild card
games three is Houston against
Jacksonville at six Houston gets the win
Pittsburgh has to go to the Chargers no
home-field advantage Steelers move on
that means in the second round of
visional round
it's Steelers at Patriots and it's
Texans at Ravens well guess what
Steelers upset the Patriots in
Foxborough
go baby but that's not where the upset
stop Houston goes into Baltimore and
upsets the Ravens to Shaun Watson moves
on setting up an AFC championship game
of the Houston Texans and the Pittsburgh
Steelers it's in Houston what an amazing
game that would be first of all
Houston's going to the Super Bowl all
right he was going there the way he was
staying Houston take me to the NFC
laughs go NFC first wild card matchup
the scenes traveled to the Cowboys and
the Packers go to the Rams Saints upset
the Cowboys in the first round of the
playoffs and the Packers upset the Rams
I have a lot of upsets Saints travel to
Minnesota for a rematch of the Minnesota
miracle and they get their revenge the
Saints from the six seed rumble
themselves to the NFC Championship game
and Atlanta going ooh we can face our in
division rivals upset by Aaron Rodgers
Aaron Rodgers against Drew Brees in the
NFC Championship game Aaron Rodgers goes
to the Super Bowl it's Aaron Rodgers
versus Shawn Watson Green Bay versus
Houston amazing super alright seems
bring me to the AFC alright here we go
alright my number one seeds the Steelers
the number two seeds the Pats so they
have the first round bye I'm gonna go to
the wild card first my number three
seeds the Chargers they will be hosting
the number six seed Houston Texans I
have the Chargers moving on to win that
football okay or not number four seed I
have the Jacksonville Jaguars I think
they will be hosting the Baltimore
Ravens in their wild card game I'm
picking the Baltimore Ravens eye they
can handle the physicality of the
Jaguars they move on so now we have the
two seed Pats hosting the three seed
chargers okay and then we have the 1
seed Steelers hosting the Ravens Wow
yeah pretty pretty cool either way I'll
be this will be really fun to watch I'm
going to pick the Chargers to be upset
the Pats as well
both have the Patriots for years they've
gone to the Super Bowl I mean even they
have to fall off at some point and their
divisional rounds are kind of the other
than last year the Titans they you know
the Texans underwhelming right and I
just I look at the you know the rest of
the AFC's got to be going gosh damn
we're sick of the Patriots like if
they're not then they all need to like
get a reality check or something because
I mean damn it's get really CH it's
unbelievable all right sitting around
just going hey we're sick of you
whooping our ass okay uh you know what
you need two livers a reality check you
do quantify that charge don't use my
words George your brain now your heart
yes right that's why I did it here I
don't know actually I use my heart I
think on that one so Chargers beat the
Pats during the AFC Championship game
Steelers Ravens one seed five seed I'm
going with the roux Steelers yes I'm
going with the Steelers and we got
Steelers charge Phillip Rivers and
company coming to town in Pittsburgh and
late January I just think it'll be a
little too cold to Steelers you're gonna
win okay Steelers are the Superbowl I'm
going with it oh yeah the NFC NFC I have
the Saints is my one seed and the
Vikings is my two seat first that's the
first round bye all right I got the Rams
as my three seed they are hosting the
number six seed Atlanta Falcons and I
saw this last year natural last year and
it'll be the same results the Falcons
will go into LA and you guys have the
Rams going down wildcard weekend yeah I
mean when I just look at the NSC I think
the worst quarterback in the playoffs is
still Jared Goff and he was definitely
the worst quarterback in the playoffs
total last year just by his performance
against the Falcon I'm sure he'll be
really happy to hear that one I'm sure
he'll want to meet us again next year a
training camp right stare you down yeah
okay and then I got the number four seed
Dallas Cowboys hosting Oh Aaron Rodgers
you always come in to Dallas and do
amazing things and screw our season or
playoffs not so fast
yes I plagiarized that from Lee Corso
but I don't care
cowboy is gonna move on they're gonna
get the revenge on the Green Bay Packers
and Aaron Rodgers um so now I got the
number one seed Saints hosting the
Falcons I'm going with the Saints to
beat the Falcons there a week to prepare
Sean Payton and company I just think
they'll be too much for the Falcons and
then we got the Cowboys going to
Minnesota a uber Peninsula I'm going
with the Cowboys Wow wash up for the
Vikings the Cowboys I just look at it
like this just a quick description the
Vikings their receivers or their offense
I don't know if it's explosive enough to
actually expose Dallas on defense and
what scares me always about the Vikings
even though their depth is a little bit
better they're gonna get worn down by
that Dallas Cowboy run gayness I think
the Cowboys pull the upset off their now
we got Saints Cowboys yeah in the NFC
Championship game Sean Payton oh when
the saints go marching in they're gone
I'll play the Steelers in the Superbowl
Thursday picture with all the animal
stains Saints Steelers Superbowl I can't
say it but I can I can't wait to see it
played all right so in this corner we
have the Texans
facing the Green Bay Packers in the
Super Bowl let go in this corner Chris
Sims we have the Pittsburgh Steelers
taking on the New Orleans Saints Adam
left go take us through how the Super
Bowl unfolds Wow
well I don't know who I'm picking yet
I'm going to do this on the fly right
now you're gonna talk it out yeah
that'll be the grand finale
I believe that early on the Houston
defensive line is pushing Green Bay
that's the story of Houston it's not
just a Shawn Watson it's what that
defense is gonna do to people and then
DeShawn's gonna make some moves but but
old number 12 old number 12 rolls right
finds Jimmy Graham in the back of the
end zone then he's got one where DJ
reader is dropped and he slips and
Rogers does his patented little scoot
hop away from the sack jumps up his legs
two minutes good huh and who is that in
the back of the end zone none other than
Davante Adams Aaron Rodgers wins his
second Super Bowl the Green Bay Packers
are your Super Bowl champions well done
Chris James I would certainly be happy
to see that what are the likelihood that
it's gonna happen though all right
Pittsburgh Steelers New Orleans Saints
Pittsburgh Steelers New Orleans Saints
in a stadium that the Saints are
familiar with because the Super Bowl is
in Atlanta this year it's correct it's
indoors with the Saints man this is a
really tough but I think it's very
evenly matched across the board I think
what really will make the difference for
me is I just think the Steelers have a
few too many playmakers for me to take
the Saints over them I think this will
be an awesome Super Bowl if you made me
break it down I don't know if the Saints
have enough difference-makers to slow
down Pittsburgh on the first the
offensive side of the ball
Pittsburgh's old line is really good we
know the receivers are the good let me
um bill should be levy on bail by that
time of the year we hope and yeah I just
look at that matchup but I'm super up on
the Steelers right now when I think of
the Saints hey the Saints are gonna move
the ball in that Pittsburgh defense too
but I think Pittsburgh's got ballers
that can change the flow of that
football game at some point whether it's
an Antonio Brown on offense making an
amazing play or a bud Dupree or Stefon
to it coming in or even my man Terrell
Edmonds making that kind of play and I'm
gonna go with the Pittsburgh Steelers to
win the Super Bowl and there it is Wow I
can't believe it so I'm looking at the
other top Saints Steelers that wasn't
sure I bat up on the fly Pittsburgh is
+1000 to win the Super Bowl this year
they're the third highest no one yep and
then Green Bay left go is plus 1212 to
one not far not far off all right guy
and we're all Emmons what a good warez
the Saints in five years I almost
thought about two elements the Saints
are plus 1600 and the Texans are plus
2000 so you picked all teams that are in
the top 10 favorites here right yeah top
10 top 11 so not not too
crazy I get to root for Aaron Rodgers
all year I know that is cool and gets a
roof or a be levy on skinny pure Big Ben
right yeah all of them I don't care
those all right I think that's it I got
them losing we set a record today oh
definitely
well you know what I don't care tell you
people out there who'd say that I'm
always the one trying to end this
podcast early no today I'm living large
let's keep it going we ran our three
right now what do you guys want to talk
about all right so I had a tuna fish
sandwich how was it tell us about it I'm
just kidding guys thank you so much as
always no matter how you interact with
Sims and Lefko we appreciate it to
everyone that's getting ready to do the
[ __ ] to play up stats this year love you
guys to everyone that's a part of the
near 400 people of the Sims and left go
fantasy league you're all screwed
because Odell Rogers is gonna win it and
we're gonna be on your baby behind nest
I cannot believe the NFL season starts
next Thursday and I want to say that
what we're gonna try and provide for you
guys next year we're going we're going
balls to the wall three podcasts a week
with our special YouTube show coming out
next Wednesday darn 'old Romo got a lot
of stuff in there that I don't even want
to spoil the surprise it's gonna be
really good yeah we did some run
throughs today Sims looked at me and
said I like this yes I like it too for
now for Sims peace out homies forfend
Rick good evening everybody and for the
lef koe man good luck to the Packers
good luck to the Steelers good luck to
everybody and if Eagles fans are upset
that'd make the playoffs in my bracket I
apologize they're still DN at Sims and
left go and talk crap to left go there's
still the Super Bowl champions guys be
well love you guys peace